सो
टूव
गो एंड ी आर
लाइव बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल लाइव आ चुके
सभी को एक बार लेट एवरी बडी कम गाइस लेट
एवरी बडी जॉइन द लाइव
सेशन ओ देखते सा तो बज गए मैं भी आ गया सा
बज जाते हैं मैं तुरंत आ जाता हूं डोंट
वरी अबाउट दैट
थिंग ओके सो आई एम यर
गा मुझे बताइए डियो वीडियो सब सही
है मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी से ऑडियो
वीडियो सब सही है क्या
यो ल
ओके मुझे ऑडियो में प्रॉब्लम आ रही थोड़ी
सी मुझे डियो में थोड़ा सा इशू आ रहा
है
ओके हां बफर हो रही है ट करेक्ट करेक्ट
करेक्ट टट
थिंग फसिंग सम
इस्ट होल्ड जस्ट होल्ड ऑन जस्ट होल्ड ऑन
गाइस जस्ट जस्ट होल्ड ऑन
गाइस लेट मी सी
वंस लेट्स सी गाइस इफ आ इट इ ओके
नाउ तो मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार अभी ऑडियो
सही हुई है कि नहीं हुई है एक बार मुझे
बताइए जरा
इस माय वॉइस क्लियर
गाइस नहीं मुझे लग रहा है दिक्कत आ रही है
मेरे फोन
पे मेरे फोन पर आवाज जो है
ना अच्छा अभी ठीक है तो कुछ प्रॉब्लम हो
गई थी मेरे ख्याल से ठीक है अभी सही है ना
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया चलो आ जाने देते सभी आ जाओ या
जल्दी से फटाफट 100 लोग 100 तुमने बोले थे
तुमने प्रॉमिस किया था 100 100
पार तुमने प्रॉमिस किया था ह पार वह
प्रॉमिस कहां गया यह बताओ अब मैं भी
प्रॉमिस तोडूंगा अपने क्लासेस के सच बता
रहा हूं मैं चलो बढ़िया अब तो ऑडियो सही
है वेरी गुड अब तुम बताओ कि प्रॉमिस मैं
अपना भी तोडू
तो लाइव आज की एंड कर दे खत्म कर दे क्या
लाइव आज की क्योंकि आप लोगों ने प्रॉमिस
फुलफिल नहीं किया अपना मैंने बोला था 100
प्लस बट आप 100 प्लस तो दिख ही नहीं रहे
कहीं से भी 50 भी नहीं है इनफैक्ट 100 तो
बात छोड़ ही
दो बात ही छोड़ दो 100 तो खैर बात ही छोड़
दो है
ना तो बताओ मुझे क्या करना चाहिए व्ट शुड
आई डू व्हाट शुड आई डू गाइस लेट मी नो
ठीक है चलो मैं वेट करता हूं वेट करता हूं
जब 100 आ जाएंगे तभी स्टार्ट करेंगे अदर
वाइज हम आज की लाइव एंड कर देंगे मतलब आज
की क्लास भी एंड कर देंगे
क्योंकि आई थिंक ऐसे नहीं हो पाएगा यार
सॉरी मैं अगर एफर्ट दे रहा हूं तो एफर्ट
तुम्हें भी देनी पड़ेगी चाहे कुछ भी हो
जाए अब तुम 10 बहाने कर लो 10 ची बोलो कि
सर जो पढ़ने वाले हैं उनको पढ़ाओ नहीं कम
से कम 100 आने चाहिए जहां पर 5000 लोगों
की कम्युनिटी बनी पड़ी है वहां अगर 100
नहीं आ रहे हैं तो फिर तो कोई फायदा ही
नहीं है ठीक है तो मैं वेट करता हूं दो
मिनट वेट करता हूं दो मतलब उसके बाद अगर
नहीं आते हैं तो फिर लाइव एंड करते हैं
कोई कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है 29 क्लासेस ऑलरेडी हो चुकी है आप लोग
उनको देखिए बग बाउंटीज सीखिए ट्स इट मैं
इससे ज्यादा तो क्या ही बोलू आप लोगों ने
बहुत हर्ट किया है यार एक तरह से हर्ट
किया है दिल दिल पे य ये सही चीज नहीं है
चलो ठीक है कोई बात नहीं सो लेट्स
वेट आईपीएल देख रहे हैं आईपीएल अगर ज्यादा
जरूरी है तो ठीक है अच्छी बात है आईपीएल
देखना 100 प्लस हो जाएंगे मैं स्टार्ट कर
दूंगा जैसे ही 100 होंगे आई विल स्टार्ट
उसके पहले तो नहीं भाई पॉसिबल ही नहीं है
आज तो नहीं है क्योंकि आज का टॉपिक बहुत
शानदार बहुत इतना शानदार होने वाला है कि
तुम आज की क्लास के बाद उस एक टॉपिक को
बहुत ज्यादा एक्सप्लोर करोगे बहुत ज्यादा
उस परे हंट करने की कोशिश करोगे शायद
तुम्हें कुछ मिल भी जाए इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
मिल जाए उसपे आज की ऐसी क्लास है और आज की
क्लास के लिए अगर तुम नहीं करोगे मतलब और
नहीं आओगे यार तो फिर दिक्कत है अब तुम
तुम यह मत बोलना भाई तुम लोग कि सर जो पढ़
रहे हैं उनको पढ़ाओ ना जो आ रहे हैं उनको
पढ़ाओ ना जो नहीं आ रहे हैं उनका लॉस है
तो ऐसे नहीं चलेगा ना यार आप खुद सोचो ना
यार मैं यहां पे क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग मैं
कोई ऐसी कुछ भी लाके नहीं फेंक देता हूं
आपके सामने मैं चाहता तो कर सकता था है ना
क्योंकि फ्री की ट्रेनिंग है क्या ही जा
रहा है और आप लोग नए-नए हैं आप लोगों को
जो बताओ वही लेकिन वो फेंकने वाली होती
नहीं है बहुत सारे अपने जो डिफ्रॉक स्टर्स
है अपने जो बग हंटर्स है स्पायरिंग बग
हंटर्स उनको बक्स मिल रहे हैं यार दे आर
गेटिंग ऑल ऑफ फेम बाउंटीज रिवार्ड्स मिल
रहे हैं उनको इस इस ट्रेनिंग के बाद ये
फ्री ट्रेनिंग के बाद तो वर्थ तो है ना
कुछ ना कुछ वैल्यूज तो है और आपको प्रो
बनना है बोलते हो प्रो बनना है मुझे बहुत
आगे तक जाना है और अटेंडेंस ही नहीं
बनाओगे फिर कैसे चलेगा यार चलो 73 हो गए अ
27 मोर लेफ्ट
सिर्फ 27 चाहिए
दैट्ची बंदा वो करके करोगे तो कोई फायदा
नहीं है और रियल में आ जाओ ठीक है एंड
धन्यवाद जो लोग सोच रहे हैं कि 100 हो
जाने चाहिए दिल से धन्यवाद आप लोगों का
ठीक
है मेरे पास एक आईडिया है बताओ इट्स द
आईडिया अपना
बताओ हां टाइमिंग कॉन्फ्लेट हो सकती है बट
100 इतने लोगों में से 100 लोग भी तो आ
सकते हैं ना यार टाइमिंग का यार मैं क्या
बोलू और भाई लॉट ऑफ पीपल आर फ्रॉम यूएसए
वी आर वर्किंग सो वल वच लेटर
ओके अब वो यूएसए वाली बात है फिर डिफरेंट
दिस इज द डिफरेंट थिंग यूएसए वाली अगर बात
है तो दैट इज दैट इज टोटली डिफरेंट
थिंग देखो
चलो ठीक
है आज तो मैं स्टार्ट करता हूं और बट क्या
होगा कि अगर आप ऐसे ही रह गए ऐसे ही करते
रहे ऐसे ही चलता रहा तो रियली लिटरली आई
विल स्टार्ट लूजिंग माय इंटरेस्ट सच में
अगर आपने इंटरेस्ट लूज किया तो मैं भी
इंटरेस्ट लूज कर दूंगा ओके सो आज का जो
टॉपिक है ना यह है
फाइंडिंग फाइंडिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग्स इनसाइड
रोबोट्स डटी एकटी ये आज का टॉपिक है
इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग्स का मतलब है फाइंडिंग
बर्गस इन रोबोट एक्सटी अब पहले ना आपको
समझना है कि वाओ यार 78 लोग हो चुके क्या
बात है 78 हो चुके क्या भाई अभी धीरे-धीरे
याद आता है क्या तुम लोगों को कि गग मंटी
की क्लास चल रही है वहां 100 प 100 करने
जाने हैं धीरे-धीरे तुम लोगों को याद आता
है क्या यार समझ नहीं आता यार
इतनी आज की जो टॉपिक है ना भाई वो अपने आप
में बहुत ही शानदार टॉपिक है बहुत खतरनाक
टॉपिक है यह बात जान जाओ
टॉपिक्स आने से पहले यह हमारा नक्स का
linkedinsign.com
पे आती है ठीक है ग्रेट तो अब गाइस लाइक
ठोक दो यार 70 79 लोग हैं लाइक नहीं ठोका
लाइक से कोई दुश्मनी है क्या कि मुझसे है
भाई ये बता दो अब फाइंडिंग इंटरेस्टिंग
थिंग्स इनसाइड robot.txt अब ये जो
robots.txt है ना यह वाकई में अपने आप में
बहुत बहुत ज्यादा अमेजिंग चीज है तुम
इमेजिन नहीं कर सकते क्या-क्या चीजें तुम
कर सकते हो . देखने में बहुत छोटा सा नाम
है छोटी सी चीज है बहुत लोगों को पता है
बहुत लोगों को नहीं पता है बहुत लोगों को
यह पता है robots.txt
होता है बट ये नहीं पता robot.txt से वो
क्याक कर सकते हैं किसी एक कंपनी के अंदर
में किसी भी प्रोग्राम के अंदर में चलिए
अब robot.txt होता क्या है पहले हम इसको
समझते हैं ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए कि
इसको हम एक्सप्लोइट कैसे करेंगे ठीक है या
कोई भी अटैकर इसको एक्सप्लोइट करता कैसे
83 पीपल क्या बात है यार अब तुम लोग यार
सच में अब अब थोड़ा सा मजा आ रहा
है देखो तुम लोग वेबसाइट जो ब्राउज करते
हो ना जैसे कोई भी वेबसाइट है जैसे हमारी
वेबसाइट है de.com ठीक है यह तुमने
वेबसाइट डायरेक्टली ब्राउज कर ली ठीक है
वे साइट अब क्या एक और तरीका क्या होता है
तुम
हमारे
तरीके से इंडेक्स जो फॉर्मेट होता है उनका
इंडेक्सिंग होता है उसके थ्रू वो कॉल्ड
पेजेस को आपके सामने लाके रख देते हैं
सिंपल सा फंडा है अब क्या बात है कि हो
सकता है कि मेरे fix.com पे कोई ऐसा
लोकेशन है कोई ऐसा पेज है मान लो मेरा
डिक्स वेबसाइट है ये क्या बात है 94 लोग आ
चुके हैं भाई 100 करके मानोगे क्या 100 कर
दिया तो फिर समझ लाओ समझ जाओ कि तुम लोग
मेरी बात का थोड़ा सा तो वैल्यू करते ही
हो तभी थोड़ी तो वैल्यू करते हो यार थोड़ी
तो रिस्पेक्ट देते हो एंड
दैट्ची सो मच सभी को 95 हो गए हैं
अहा चलो अब मान लो मेरे वेबसाइट पे एक
लोकेशन है सीक्रेट ये लोकेशन है एक पेज है
सीक्रेट मैं नहीं चाहता कि जब कोई भी बंदा
डेनिक्स के वेब पेजेस को सर्च करें तो मैं
नहीं चाहता भैया कि ये सीक्रेट वाला पेज
यहां पे लिस्ट होके आए सिंपल सा सिंपल सा
फंडा है ठीक है बस सिंपल सा जैसे मैं इन
यूआरएल यहां पे यहां पे डि फ्रक्स ऐसे
करके मैंने किया अब यहां पे डिफ्रॉक जैसे
मैंने किया तो यहां पे डिक्स रिलेटेड जो
भी अ यूआरएल है वो आ गए ठीक है अब मैंने
यहां पे इनटाइटल कर दिया डि फ्रक्स तो
टाइटल जो भी डिफ्रॉक्ड है वो सारे आ गए
जैसे एक ये पेज भी आ गया वेरीफाई
सर्टिफिकेट का फिर ये मास्टर क्लास का फिर
अलग-अलग पेजेस आ गए जितने भी पेजेस है मैं
नहीं चाहता इस लिस्ट में मुझे ये सीक्रेट
वाला पेज भी आए मुझे ये सीक्रेट वाला पेज
भी दिखे 94 है छह लोग और अब मैं इसको
क्योंकि हाइड करना चाहता हूं मैं चाहता
हूं कि यह सर्च इंजन के रिजल्ट्स में यह
चीज पेज आए ही ना सीक्रेट इसलिए इन्वेंशन
हुआ रोबोट्स डटी एक्सटी का रोबोट्स डटी
एक्टी का अब ये रोबोट डटी एक्टी क्या करता
है
यह क्या करता है इसमें एक रूल होता है रूल
क्या होता है अलाउ का और एक रूल होता है
आपके डिस अलाउ का दो रूल्स होते हैं इसमें
अलाउ में अलाउ में जो जो पेजेस पाथ यहां
पर डाले होते हैं वो सारे अलाउड होते हैं
. में जैसे मान लो स्लश मतलब पूरी पाथ
मेरी अलाउड है वेबसाइट की वेब पोर्टल की
ओहो क्या बात है 100 हो ग कर दिया 100 तुम
लोगों ने अबकी बार 100 पार कर दिया चलो
चलो अच्छी बात है भाई बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया धन्यवाद सभी को लेकिन आप लोग अपने
लिए आते हो यार आप देखो आप लोग 100 आते हो
ना मैं आपको थैंक यू क्यों बोल रहा हूं
मैं आपको थैंक यू बस यूं ही बोल रहा हूं
बिना मतलब का आपको थैंक यू में बोल बोलना
ही नहीं चाहिए आपको ना थैंक यू क्योंकि आप
लोग यार अपने लिए आ रहे हो और मैं जो
बोलता हूं आपके लिए बोलता हूं ठीक है आओगे
तो बढ़िया है सीधी सधी बात है हा मेरा एक
इसमें बेनिफिट क्या होता है मैं आपको
बताता हूं जैसे 100 लोग आए ना तो मेरे को
मजा आता है मतलब ज्यादा लोग आएंगे अभी 200
आ जाओ खतरनाक और टॉपिक्स लाऊंगा मैं फिर
आगे क्लासेस में तुमको सरप्राइज देने की
बात मैंने कही थी 200 अगर आ गए उसके बाद
मैं ऐसे-ऐसे टॉपिक्स कुछ और चीजें लेकर
बताऊंगा जो तुम सोच भी नहीं सकते इमेजिन
नहीं कर सकते बक बाउंटीज के अंदर की मैं
बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है कहीं और की बात
नहीं कर रहा मैं जो आपको कहीं नहीं मिलेगा
याद रखिएगा ओके और डिस अलाउ में वो पेजेस
के पाथ रहते हैं जो बेसिकली वेबसाइट ओनर्स
नहीं चाहते कि
स्क्रॉल करके और उनको सर्च रिजल्ट्स में
दिखाए मतलब वोह हिडन पेजेस
है ठीक है वो हिडन पेजेस है दे आर ऑल हिडन
पेजेस तो यह चीज रोबोट डटी करती है सिंपल
ट एस सिंपल एट अब मैं क्या करता हूं एक
लाइव एग्जांपल के थ्रू आपको दिखाता हूं
जैसे मैं जाता हूं netflix.com
पेरो जितने भी वेबसाइट्स है ऑलमोस्ट सब
में robot.txt आपको मिल जाएंगे कहीं-कहीं
नहीं भी मिलेंगे बट ऑलमोस्ट सब में मिल
जाएंगे अब मैं जब
netflix.com
इट ठीक है अब मैं जब इन पे गया तो यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा यूजर एजेंट स्टार सारे
यूजर एजेंट यहां पे अलाउड है यहां पे अलाउ
लिस्ट में स्लैश है यानी पाथ पूरी अलाउड
है भैया सब क्रॉल करो भाई
अब यहां
पर डिस अलाउ में यह जो पाथ है यहां पर तो
इन पथ्स को नेटफ नहीं चाहता कि ग या कोई
भी सर्च इंजन या याहू हो या कोई भी डग डग
हो कोई भी सर्च इंजन हो उसको इनको क्रॉल
करें ठीक है इनको क्रॉल करें इनको
रिजल्ट्स में दिखाए अब इन पाथ में कुछ
प्राइवेट या कुछ ऐसे पाथ हो सकते हैं जहां
पे कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें होस्ट हो रही है
कोई लॉगइन पैनल हो सकता है जिसम हम ब्रूट
फोर्स कर सकते हैं कोई एक ऐसा वेब पेज हो
सकता है जो एक अलग ही एक वेब पेज है उस
वेबसाइट पे हमें जनरली हमने बॉब शूट से
क्रॉल किया स्पाइडर की हमें मिला ही नहीं
लेट्स सपोज हमें नहीं मिला लेकिन हमें
यहां पे हम डायरेक्टली जब एक्सेस करें वो
पाथ हमें मिल रहा है और वहां पे कुछ ऐसी
चीजें हैं जो हमारे लिए वहां हो सकता है
एक सर्च पैनल हो जहां हम एक्सेसेस के लिए
ट्राई कर सकते हैं वहां पे एक ऐसी
डायरेक्टरी हो हम वहां प उस पाथ को फज
करके डायरेक्टरी फज करके हम कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग डायरेक्टरी एंड पॉइंट खोद
सकते हैं समझ में आ रहा है एडमिन पैनल
एसकल इंजेक्शन के बेसिकली ऑथेंटिकेशन
बायपास पेलोड्स को यूज कर सकते हैं तो देर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स आप दिमाग में सोचोगे तो
बहुत कुछ आएगा ओ भाई 107 हो गया क्या अरे
तुम लोग यार ऐसे इतना अब यह प्यार हजम
नहीं हो रहा यार इतना तुम लोग प्यार दिखा
रहे हो सब यह हजम क्यों नहीं हो रहा मुझे
अ यह कोई कोई बस करो भाई रुलाओगे
क्या बस करो भाई रुलाओगे क्या आज हां रुला
दिया या तुम लोगों
ने यानी कि
ना करे ठीक है यह सारी पेजेस को ग चाहता
है यह
अब इसमें ना कुछ कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हो
सकती है इट माइट बी पॉसिबल अब क्योंकि ये
तो
नहीं नहीं ऐसा नहीं है मिलता है सार
ऑलमोस्ट मिलता है ठीक है चलिए अब हम सॉरी
नाउ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हमें क्या
करना है सिंपल इसका मतलब समझ गए आप कि
अलाउड लिस्ट है उसको छोड़ दो ऑलरेडी अलाउड
है डिस अलाउ में कुछ ऐसे पाथ खोजने की
कोशिश करो जिस पर हम फरदर एक्शन ले सकते
हैं ठीक है तो चलिए हम एक काम करते हैं हम
ओपन बक बाउटी पर चलते हैं ओपन बग बाउंट से
कोई टारगेट लेते हैं डायरेक्ट लाइव हंटिंग
करेंगे यार
ब क्राउड पर भी चलते हैं बग
क्राउड लेट्स ओपन बग
क्राउड लेट्स गो टू इंगेजमेंट्स
ओके ओके सारे प्रोग्राम आ ग लिस्ट ओके
बढ़िया तो यहां भी चलते दो चीज दोनों चलते
हैं एंड यह भी ले सकते हैं इनटाइटल
इनटाइटल ले सकते हैं रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर
[संगीत]
इनटाइटल
बग बग
बाउंट बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम कर लेते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है यहां से भी तीनों में से
कहीं से भी ले लेंगे अब देखो यहां पर क्या
कैसे करना है देखो हर एक ना प्रोसेस को
समझो हर एक प्रोसेस को समझो य कितना
इंटरेस्टिंग होगा तुम खोजते रहोगे तुम इस
क्लास के बाद से चलो जैसे मैं कुछ
प्रोग्राम य टेस्ट वाले प्रोग्राम से इन
पे चलते हैं टाफी 248 रेजर गेम एयस एक
रिस्पांस लीज इंफो एल
एल्टो चलिए इन सब पे चलते हैं चलिए नाउ
व्हाट वी नीड टू डू जैसे यहां पे एक
वेबसाइट है टाय चलिए अब यहां पे इसको
मैंने कॉपी किया अब तुम लोग क्या कर सकते
हो इसके सारे सब डोमेन डोमेन सारे इन
स्कोप है ठीक है सारे इन स्कोप है ना अब
मैं क्या कर सकता हूं मैं सारे सब डोमस को
फाइंड करूंगा बेसिकली रोबोट
txt.gz
किया हमने ओपन किया टाफ य यह वाली वेबसाइट
है अब हम इसके एक robots.txt पे चलते हैं
robots.txt लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग
कुछ है क्या अलाउड में यह है कुछ नहीं यार
बेकार हैय कुछ भी नहीं है इसको हटा दो चलो
अब चलते हैं डटा फी हटाओ
भाई 204 t.com अरे इसमें ट्रेजर कुछ मिले
तब तो लेट्स ओपन दिस वेबसाइट अभी देखो
कितना मजा आएगा अभी अभी तो तभी तो शुरुआत
हुई है तुम्हें मजा नहीं आया तो बोलना आज
यह वेबसाइट आ
गई लेट्स ओपन रोबोट
रो यूनिवर्स ओपन करते देखते हैं अलाउ ला
क्या भाई यार ये क्या है यह व्हाट इज
दिस
ो आई थिंक देर शुड बी ओके कुछ भी नहीं
यहां पे हटाओ ये उसके बाद sx4 ए एक रेसड
यके यूके की वेबसाइट है इसको चलो इसको
ट्राई मारते हैं क्या बात है यार लेट्स
ट्राई इट ट्रा इट ट्राई इट वेलकम वेलकम
ठीक है भैया चलो स्ल रोबोट डटी एक्टी देन
एंटर एंड यहां पर क्या आ रहा है गाइस देखो
हां यहां पे एक चीज क्या मिली मुझे यहां
पे यूजर ए ठीक है भैया यहां पे देखो देखो
देखो देखो देखो देखो रिस्ट्रिक्टिंग देखो
रोबोट्स स्पाइडर्स एंड सर्च इंजंस यूज दिस
फाइल टू डिटरमाइंड व्हिच कंटेंट दे शुड
नॉट क्रॉल वाइल इंडेक्सिंग योर वेबसाइट
बट्स को रोकती है ये जो जो
google's को रोकती है y robot.txt
है इस फाइल को तुम्हें कुछ नहीं करना है
नहीं स्क्रॉल करना यूजर को नहीं दिखाना
भैया यूजर से हाइड करके रखने का है तो अब
देखो यहां स्लश एडमिन डिस अलाउ में समझ
में आ रहा है डिस अलाउ में स्लश इमेजेस है
नाउ दिस इज द थिंग मुझे स्लश एडमिन मिली
है तो मैं क्या करूंगा स्लश एडमिन पर जाके
देखूंगा क्या है भाई यहां पर हमारे लिए
क्या रखा है हमारे लिए जो हाइड करके रखा
है अच्छा ये लॉगइन पेज है ये वर्डप्रेस का
सिंपल सा लॉग इन पेज है और कुछ है नहीं
भाई तो मुझे लगा कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ और
होगा बट यह नॉर्मल सा लॉगिन पेज है एडमिन
और एडमिन वाला तो यह वर्डप्रेस का लॉगइन
पेज है नथिंग एल्स हालांकि हम यहां पे भी
ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हैं बट स्टिल अभी कुछ
नहीं कर रहे अभी कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग हमें
नहीं मिला बट क्योंकि ये वर्डप्रेस की है
तो इसको हम यहां पे रहने देते हैं चलिए अब
आते हैं यहां पे एल्टो है यहां पे एंड लीज
है चलिए लीज
इफोन
r.in चलिए लीज
हम यहां पे चलते हैं robots.txt पे
robots.txt
एंड ओ यहां हमें कुछ मिला है गाइस गाइस वी
गॉट इट हियर अ वी गॉट समथिंग हियर अ हमें
तीन डिस अलाउ मिले हैं अलाउ को गोली मारो
अलाउ से मतलब नहीं है डिस अलाउ से मतलब है
तीन डिस अलाउ मिले हैं ये एक तो अरे एक
प्राइवेट करके भी है चलो इसको भी देखते
हैं और एक है रेस बैच पीडीएफ चलो ये भी
देखते हैं ये भी इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा है
मुझे तो तो लीज डॉट इसी पर चलते हैं इसी
इसी पर देखते हैं चलो नेक्स्ट वाले में
खोल ले क्या ओके एक नया टाम में ओपन कर
लेते हैं r.in
को एंड यहां से उठाने
का एंड यहां देखने का कि यह क्या है लेट्स
सी डॉ पीडीएफ ड पीएपी यानी पीडीएफ फाइल
होगी लेट्स सी इट्स ओपनिंग और
नॉट लेट्स लेट्स सी लेट्स सी इट शुड ओपन
आई डोंट नो देखते हैं कुछ है भी कि नहीं
है हालाकि पीडी
ओहो ओके
सो ओके सो दिस इज अ पीडीएफ फाइल दैट दे
डोंट वांट टू गेट कॉल्ड बाय सोशल सॉरी बाय
सर्च इंजन एंड वी फाउंड इट फ्रॉम रो राइट
सो हियर इज अ पीडीएफ फाइल ये लंबा सा
पीडीएफ फाइल है क्या 44 पेज का है 44 पेज
का पीडीएफ है आई डोंट नो यह क्या है बट
मैकडोनाल्ड एंड मोनरो स्पी साइड स्टेज 20
2024 फाइनल इंडिविजुअल टाइम्स इन पोजीशन
ऑर्डर
ओके सो दिस इज समथिंग ओके पैरी एंड्रू
स्टीवन यह कुछ कुछ डाटा है डेविड विल्सन
कइले डोनाल्ड पीकॉक ओके केनी फोगो काइली
मॉरिसन काइल मॉरिसन एडी नोबल डोनाल्ड मुरे
कुछ पता नहीं कुछ है यहां पे ठीक है कुछ
कुछ डेटा है ठीक है चलिए एक और है मैं ये
देखता हूं मेरे को प्राइवेट में कुछ
ज्यादा इंटरेस्ट आ रहा है तो चलो प्राइवेट
वाला देखते हैं एक बार ये तो कुछ पीडीएफ
फाइल है ठीक है कुछ हो सकता है इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर भी हो सकता है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
इंफॉर्मेशन जो इनको डिस्क्लोज नहीं करनी
चाहिए वो अगर हो जाती है तो आप इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर में वो बग रिपोर्ट कर सकते हो
सो प्राइवेट ब ओ हो हो हो हो वेट वेट वेट
वेट गाइस वेट गाइस वेट यह क्या है यह एक
ये एक पैनल है गाइस दिस इज अ प्राइवेट
लॉगइन पैनल प्राइवेट लॉगइन प पैनल है भाई
प्राइवेट लॉगइन पैनल मिला है 125 लोग आ गए
हैं अरे भाई 125 लोग आ गए क्या ये कौन सी
यह काहे इतना काहे प्यार दिखा रहे हो भाई
आज इतना प्यार काहे दिखा रहे हो यह देखो
क्या मिला हमें इतना प्यार दिखाओगे तो ऐसे
ही मिलेगा ये देखो एडमिन पैनल एक मिला या
जो कहो एक प्राइवेट लॉगइन पैनल मिला हमें
एंड दिस इज वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग
दिस इज अ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग
मतलब ठीक है कुछ देखते हैं यार क्या है
एडमिन एड एडमिन
टूथ नहीं गलत है
एडमिन एडमिन
रूट गलत है रूट टूर इज इट राइट रूट
एडमिन कुछ है नहीं चलो इसको हम ब्रूट
फोर्स करके एक बार देखेंगे जब ऐसा एडमिन
पैनल मिल बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज होती है
इसके अलावा तुम क्या कर सकते हो गाइस सुनो
ये एक पाथ मिल गया प्राइवेट यह पाथ ये पाथ
पे तुम डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हो
कि नहीं और बोलो कौन सा टूल यू करोगे उसके
लिए सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग टूल कौन सा है बताओ
जल्दी चैट में सभी लोग बताओ जल्दी जल्दी
बताओ जल्दी बताओ जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
फास्ट फास्ट इसमें डायरेक्टरी ड फोर्स के
लिए कौन सा टूल यूज
करेंगे इंटरेस्टिंग वाली सबसे खतरनाक टूल
मैंने बताया था मेरे को काफी अच्छा लगता
है वो टूल बट फिर भी आप लोगों से पूछ रहा
हूं डीर बर वाई आई कौन सा टूल है भाई बताओ
जल्दी अरे दिव्यांश से एक आंसर मिला बाकी
तो र बस्टर ब बब
सूट ठीक है र बस्टर ठीक है बॉब शूट एफ एफ
यू एफ यह हुई ना बात य वही में बोल रहा था
यार एफफ य डीई सर्च भी यूज कर सकते हो यू
कैन यूज डीआर सर्च ट इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग
टूल गो बस्टर यू कैन आल्सो यूज ग्रेट बट
एफफ य जो है वो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल मुझे
लगता है एफएफ यूएफ यू कैन यूज नो नो इशू
तो ये भी हम कर सकते हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
जब ऐसी कोई डायरेक्टरी मिले ना जो पाथ
मिले जो इंटरेस्टिंग पाथ हो उसपे
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स मारो और देखो कुछ
और छिपा है क्या उसके
अंदर ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट
राइट
सिंपल तो सबसे पहले भैया यहां पे मेरे को
मन कर रहा है ना एक एक ब्रूट फोर्स करने
का डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स पहले करने का
तो चलिए पहले डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स करते
हैं उसके लिए यूएफ टूल का यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा एंड फॉर दैट आई नीड माय काली मशीन
और माय
भाई क्या हो रहा है हट एग्जीक्यूट हो जा
पासवर्ड मांगेगा पासवर्ड यार क्या था
पासवर्ड यही था क्या हां चलो बहुत बढ़िया
तो यहां पे
हमने सॉरी एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी लॉग इन कर
लिया है अपने मशीन में नाउ हियर वी आर
गोइंग टू यूज एफएफ यूएफ एफएफ यूएफ ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है मेरे मशीन पे तो अलग से आप
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा अगर आपका इंस्टॉल नहीं
होगा तो एक चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं
एफएफ यूएफ गो में रिटन है गो में आपको
सिंपल ये कमांड डाला है गो इंस्टॉल दिस वन
ओके दिस वन यू हैव टू जस्ट कॉपी इट यू हैव
टू जस्ट पेस्ट इट एंड इट विल इंस्टॉल एफएफ
यूएफ बट इसके पहले एक चीज हमेशा ध्यान
रखिएगा यह क्योंकि गो में रिटेन है तो
आपको यहां पे एप्ट अपडेट पहले कमांड चला
देना
है मैं एक तरह से मैं रिवाइज ही करवा रहा
हूं आपको ठीक
है ओके
नाउ यह कमांड चलाने के बाद आपका गो
लैंग्वेज जो है ना गो लैंग इंस्टॉल होना
चाहिए तो एप्ट इंस्टॉल गोलंग ये कर
लीजिएगा गोलंग को इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा मेरा
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल है एंड देन गो का पाथ सेट
कर लीजिएगा ठीक है पाथ सेट करना बहुत
जरूरी है पाथ सेट करने का मतलब है बेसिकली
आप गो का जो डायरेक्टरी है उसका
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल जिसको आप बोलते हैं
विंडोज में सेट करते हैं ना वही पाथ आप
सेट कर रहे हैं तो डायरेक्टली आपका टूल जो
है एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा बिना गो के पाथ पे
गए हुए तो उसको मैंने यहां पे सेट किया है
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं विम से डॉट बैश
बैश आरसी में ही शायद था मेरा तो विम बैश
आरसी मैं दिखाता हूं जी हां नीचे यहां पे
देखिएगा तो बस ये दो लाइंस आपको बैश आरसी
या डॉट प्राइल या ड
जए z एएच आरसी जो भी आप शेल यूज़ कर रहे
हो उसमें डालने का है तो यहां पे आपको ये
दो लाइन डालना है एक्सपोर्ट गो पाथ एंड गो
पाथ ये एक गो पाथ वेरिएबल जो है आप जो बना
रहे हैं उसके अंदर क्या डाल रहे हैं डॉलर
होम स् गो यानी जो भी होम का लोकेशन होगा
फिलहाल स्ल रूट है ये तो वो लोकेशन स्लश
गो उस पे आपका पाथ सेट हो जाएगा एंड फिर
एक्सपोर्ट पाथ को करके आप गो रूट का यानी
कि गो का जो रूट डायरेक्टरी है एंड उस
स्लैश बिन वाले फोल्डर को आप यहां पे
मेंशन कर रहे हैं सिंपल तो यहां पे आप ये
चीज सेट कर लीजिएगा ठीक है
दैट्ची है इसमें एक हम यूज ू करेंगे ऑप्शन
वह हम यूज करेंगे स्टेटस कोड के लिए देखते
हैं कहां गया कहां गया एमसी हान एमसी मैच
कोड जो मैच जो ऑप्शन है मैचिंग ऑप्शन तो
ये स्टेटस कोड्स को मैच करता है तो
डिफॉल्ट इसका 200 यह वाली स्टेटस कोड है
200 से लेकर 299 301 302 307 401 403 405
500 बट हम यहां पे इतना इतना सारी इतनी
सारी चीजें नहीं करने वाले हैं हम क्या
करेंगे गाइस लेट्स सी एफएफ यूएफ और हमें
एक एक डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट भी चाहिए याद
रखिएगा वी नीड अ डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट फॉर
फजिंग ठीक है तो डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट जो है
मेरे पास वो आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं वो है
फज एकटी ये मैंने कहां से लिया ये फज एकटी
ये मैंने ली है इन भाई साहब के एक
रिपोजिटरी से यहां पे फर्सड रिपोजिटरी से
आपको यह मिल जाएगा अगर आपको चाहिए तो अदर
वाइज आई एम जस्ट गिविंग यू दिस लिंक इन द
लाइव चैट चैट सेक्शन यू कैन जस्ट गेट इट
फ्रॉम
हियर ठीक है मैंने भेज दिया है आज तो भाई
तुम लोग ने सच में यार
मतलब बहुत रुला दिया यार तुम लोगों ने
खुशी के आंसू मेरे निकल रहे हैं अभी भी
115 लोग अभी लाइव देख रहे
हैं मेरे से अब बहुत रोना आ रहा है यार
चलो गुड तो अब फर्स डटी एक्टी यहां पे हम
यूज कर रहे हैं इसके अंदर कितने कितने
डायरेक्टरीज लाइक मतलब पेलोड्स कितने हैं
डायरेक्टरी जो पे लोट्स है बेसिकली जिस
जिसको ये फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेगा जो भी
वड लिस्ट बोल लो डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट तो मैं
कट फटी करता हूं तो इसमें अच्छा बहुत सारे
हैं डब्ल्यू स हान एल लगा लेते हैं डब्लू
सफन एल लगा के वर्ड लिस्ट वर्ड काउंट कर
लेते हैं
5329 5329 वर्ड्स को यह टेस्टिंग हम
करेंगे
दैट्ची जो पाथ पे हम हंट करने वाले हैं
ये वाला पाथ चाहिए भैया जिसम हम रूट फोर्स
करने का है तो ये पाथ हमने यहां से कॉपी
मारा यहां एफएफ यूएफ चलाया हाइन य यूआरएल
के लिए हम देते हैं हान य दिया और हमने
पाथ मेंशन कर दिया अब इस पे प्राइवेट के
बाद हमें फज करना है तो स्लैश देके एफ यड
ज यहां लगा देंगे क्योंकि हमें इसपे फज
करना है हान ड दे देंगे वर्डलिस्ट के लिए
एंड वर्डलिस्ट का नाम मेंशन कर देंगे फड t
एकटी दैट्ची
[संगीत]
हां जी अब ठीक है न w1t एकटी हमने ये चीज
दे दी और हान एमसी लगा देंगे मैच कर के
लिए हमें 200 वाले ओनली चाहिए जो वर्किंग
है जहां पर हम एक्सेस कर पाते हैं
डायरेक्टरी को ये कर सकते हैं स्लश में आप
403 भी लगा सकते हैं कोई फॉर बिडेन
डायरेक्टरी मिल गई तो कुछ ट्राई मारने का
कोशिश करेंगे है ना फॉर विडेन वाली ओके
कोई बात नहीं करण अरे कोई दिक्कत नहीं आज
तो यार कुछ नए-नए नाम मुझे दिख रहे हैं
यार चलो ये लोग तो पुराने हैं ये लोग तो
रेगुलर आते हैं ताहिर इज रेगुलर
इट्स डी इज रेगुलर आरसी टेक मींस दिव्यांश
मिश्रा इज रेगुलर लो जेंस रेगुलर हैं जो
रेगुलर होते हैं उनका नाम मुझे याद रहता
है
बेसिकली काफी लोग है रेगुलर बट कुछ नए भी
हैं तो इंटरेस्टिंग है चलो बढ़िया बढ़िया
आप लोग या डेली आओ ना डेली आओगे क्या ऐसे
मतलब हर क्लास में आओगे तो बताओ अगर तुम
लोग इस तरीके के प्रेजेंस रखोगे तो सच बता
रहा हूं मतलब दिमाग खराब हो जाएगा
तुम्हारा
कंटेंट देख देख के ठीक है तो 403 मैंने
क्यों लिया यहां पर स्टेटस कोड क्योंकि
403 इज अ फॉर बिडेन पेज और लोकेशन जिसको
हम बायपास करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं 40
बायपास करने के बहुत सारे तरीके होते हैं
देर आर मल्टीपल डिफरेंट डिफरेंट वेज हियर
एंड उसका एक कलेक्शन है मेरे पास एक बंदे
का तो उस परे हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो लेट्स
सी ग्रेट ट आप लोग देखो आप लोग ना न्यू जो
क्लासेस आती है ना तो न्यू क्लासेस को उस
टाइम देख सकते हो जरूरी नहीं है कि अब
पुरानी क्लासेस को आपको करनी और रेकन का
सब सेशन चल रहा था ना तब एक दूसरे से
कनेक्टेड ज्यादा होते थे तब आपको पहली
क्लासेस देखनी होती थी अब जो है नई-नई
बग्स आती हैं हर क्लास में तो आप उस क्लास
को प्रेजेंटली देख सकते हो पुरानी वाली
क्लास बाद में फिर देख लो सिंपल जरूरी
नहीं है कि आज की क्लास या अपकमिंग
क्लासेस को देखने के लिए पहले की क्लासेस
कंप्लीट होनी ही चाहिए ऐसा कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है ठीक ठीक है तो यह
सोच के अगर नहीं आते थे तो ऐसा मत सोचना
भाई ग्रेट ग्रेट प्रण है ग्रेट
ग्रेट या या अच्छी बात है यार मैं कहां
बोल रहा हूं बुरी बात है ब्रेव बिग
गेमिंग इस टाइम कोई स्कूल में
है क्या बात है अरे तुम लोग बस रहो ना मैं
देखो कितने देर तुम लोग जितनी प्रेजेंस जब
तक रहोगे मैं उतनी क्लासेस उतनी देर तक
क्लासेस ले सकता हूं सच बता रहा हूं मैं
चाहे फ्री की है है तब भी क्यों नहीं मैं
5 घंटे पढ़ा दूंगा लगातार भाई तुम लोग पढ़
नहीं पाओगे तुम लोग खुद ही भाग जाओगे बात
ये है तुम देखना थोड़ी देर बाद जैसे अभी
121 है ना प्रेजेंस तुम देखना कुछ टाइम के
बाद लगभग आधे घंटे एक घंटे के बाद देखना
प्रेजेंस कैसे कम हो जाती है क्योंकि तुम
लोग नहीं बैठ सकते उतनी
टेम ओके तो यहां पे दो हमने ये लगा दिए
अच्छी बात है और अब हम ट्राई करेंगे कुछ
हमें मिल जाए तो शायद एफएफ यूएफ हान यू ये
पूरा पाथ दे दिया जिस पे हमें इसके आगे
हमें चाहिए कि अब इसके आगे जो जो चीज आए
ना इस वर्डलिस्ट से उठके आए और मुझे बताए
भाई कि कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग कीवर्ड मिल रहे
हैं क्या ऐसा डायरेक्टरी खोजने के लिए
एंटर करते हैं लेट्स
सी कुछ हमें तो नहीं मिला अभी
तक ओके कुछ नहीं
मिला वी डिड नॉट गेट एनीथिंग राइट यट चल
रहा है हमारा फजिंग भाई अब इसी को थोड़ा
सा वीडियो फोटो डाल के कुछ लोग तलब वो
लिंकन न प डाल के या ा पर डाल के हैकिंग
का बता दे कि हैकर हूं मैं
हैकर आज रात का खाना
डिलीट कर दूंगा ू डिलीट ह डालना बंद कर
दूंगा
मैं चैलेंज है और
क्या बिल्कुल
चलो तो हमें कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग मिला नहीं
क्योंकि हमारे 5000 कुछ ही डायरेक्टरी
वर्डलिस्ट थे बहुत छोटी सी वर्डलिस्ट थीय
हम बड़ा वर्डलिस्ट भी यूज कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है बट
स्टिल जितनी हमारे पास थी वर्डलिस्ट इसमें
हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ मिला तो नहीं
है ओके एक कुछ चीज मिला है एक सेकंड सो
दिस थिंग अच्छा हमें कुछ चीज मिला है हमें
एक चीज मिली है 403 पे मिली है वाओ ग्रेट
इट्स अ ग्रेट थिंग 403 इज आल्सो ग्रेट अ
403 पे काफी सारी चीजें मिली है यहां पे
ये देखो आप 403 का कमाल देख रहे हो ये
होती है 403 का कमाल इन्होंने एटी एक्सेस
डेव इसको फॉर बिडेन करके रखा है एक एड t
एकटी एटी एक् का बैकअप फाइल भी है यहां पे
बट इनको इन्होंने फॉर बिडेन करके रखा हुआ
उसको एक्सेस को फॉर बिन कर दिया
है ओके नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ भाई और कुछ
है
क्या एसटी यूजर्स है ओके
ओके एसवी ए डायरेक्टरी ये बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग डायरेक्टरी होती है इन्होने
इसको बंद करके रखा है अच्छा चलो डॉट
एसवीएन वाली जो है ना 403 है चलो मुझे डॉट
एसवीएन वाला एक्सप्लोर करके देखने का है
तो लेट्स एक्सप्लोर डॉट एसवी प्राइवेट के
बाद डॉट एसवी एन देखते हैं क्या है ये फॉर
बिडेन होगा मुझे पता था ये फॉर्ब
डायरेक्टरी है बट क्या होता है ना फॉर्ब
जब 403 फॉर्ब होती है ना चीजें अ फॉर्ब
चीजें तो उसको थोड़ा बायपास करने का हम
ट्राई कर सकते हैं एंड इसके लिए ना मेरे
पास एक बहुत मस्त कंटेंट है पीडीएफ है यह
पीडीएफ में यह जो पीडीएफ आपको दिख रही है
यहां पे यह पीडीएफ तो उसके लिए आपको टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है क्यों टेंशन नहीं लेनी है
भैया क्योंकि मैं क्या करने वाला हूं
दिखाता हूं आपको
सॉरी व्ट आई एम गोइंग टू डू मैं इस पीडीएफ
को मैं इस पीडीएफ को
हमारे हमारे डिफर निक्स अकेडमी पे जब आप
जाओगे अरे भैया हट जाओ हमारे पप को
इंस्टॉल कर लोगे आप तो इसके यह वाली जो
कोर्स है फ्री साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्री वाली
है जो ₹ वाली कोर्स इसके कंटेंट में यहां
बग बाउंडी रिसोर्सेस के अंदर ना इसको मैं
अपलोड कर दूंगा ठीक है तो याद रखिएगा
ध्यान से आप लोगों को बस क्या करना है
डेनिक्स अकेडमी
माय इंस्टिट्यूट प फ्रॉम एल प् एल ए स्टो
एंड यहां से इसको इंस्टॉल करने के बाद
आपसे एक कोड मांगेगा जो कोड जो कोड आपका
होता
है ऑर्ग कोड जिसको बोलते हैं वो ऑर्ग कोड
जो है यह वाली कोड है मैं आपको दिखा भी
देता
हूं यह ऑर्ग कोड है यह ऑर्ग कोड आप डालिए
एंड आप वहां पे हमारे ऐप में लॉग इन हो
जाएंगे सो दिस इज द ऑर्ग कोड दैट यू हैव
टू बीडी आईवी एफ वाई ठीक है ये और कोड है
ये आईओएस वाले यूजर्स के लिए है बीडी आईवी
एफवा ठीक है तो आप अपने कोर्सेस को भी
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं जो कोर्सेस आपने
ऑलरेडी लिए हुए हैं आईओएस यूजर्स के लिए
ये चलिए ओके डन डन आ डन चलिए मैं इसको
करता
हूं अब चलिए आ जाते हैं इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
पे तो यहां पे हमें एक एसवीएन वाला मिला
अरे भाई कहां गए एसबीएन वाले फॉर बिडेन है
अब मेरे पास ये एक पीडीएफ कंटेंट है लेट्स
ओपन दिस पीडीएफ कंटेंट
403 बायपास वाला इसको थोड़ा सा जूम करने
का
है अब यहां पर क्या है ना 403 फॉर बिडेन
एरर इंडिकेट ट द सर्वर अंडरस्टैंड द
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है बट कांट प्रोवाइड एडिशनल
एक्सेस ठीक है कांट प्रोवाइड क्या बोल रहे
हो भाई सर जी मैं स्पैम कमेंट नहीं कर रहा
हूं बस बताना चाहता हूं कि मेरे को आपकी
वेबसाइट पर एक छोटा सा बग मिला है आपको
कैसे रिपोर्ट करूं करण सिंपल वेबसाइट प एक
ईमेल दी गई होगी आप जाइएगा वहां से आप
हमें डायरेक्टली मेल कर सकते हैं बट याद
रखिएगा अभी हम कोई बाउंट ंटी नहीं देते
हैं ठीक है तो आप सिंपली एक रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर अ रिपोर्ट जो है बेसिकली सिंपल
सा एक रिस्पांसिबल रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
ओके चलिए अब यहां पे बट कैन नॉट प्रोवाइड
एडिशनल एक्सेस दिस मींस दैट द वेब पेज यू
आर ट्राइट ओपन इन योर ब्राउजर इज अ
रिसोर्स दैट यू आर नॉट अलाउड टू एक्सेस अब
इसको बायपास कैसे कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो
हम यूआरएल पाथ में यह चीजें ड करके ना हम
बायपास करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं 403 का
ठीक है उसके बाद कुछ इस तरीके सी चीजें
बायपास की जा सकती है जो यहां पर आपको
मिला हुआ है ठीक है यहां पे उसके बाद आप
हेडर्स में कुछ इस तरह की हेडर्स को डाल
के बायपास कर सकते हैं ठीक है एंड बेसिकली
यहां पे और कुछ रिसोर्सेस हैं जो यहां पे
बेसिकली ये रिसोर्सेस है दैट यू कैन यूज
टू बायपास थिंग्स ठीक है तो 403 बायपास
यहां पे एक रिसोर्स है देन यहां पे एक ये
403 बायपास रिसोर्स है आप इन रिसोर्सेस को
देख सकते हैं एंड यू कैन ट्राई टू बायपास
इट राइट तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हो लाइक
हियर यहां पे आप इस तरीके से चला सकते हैं
एक टूल सेट बनी हुई है यहां पे एंड यहां
पे कुछ इसी तरीके से ये भी फिर बायपास
वाली चीज है अलग-अलग तरह के ये टूल यूज़
कर सकते हैं मतलब इन लोगों ने क्या किया
ये टूल बना दिया एक python3 बायपास कैसे
करें तो सिंपल इसमें क्या करना है python3
से 403 बाईपास 2 h लगा दिया यूआरएल दे दो
भाई और प्रोवाइड द पाथ तो इन्होंने क्या
किया सिंपल सा
फंडा यूज केस में 403 वापास पवा न रए दे
दिया और हान p एडमिन इस पाथ को पाथ पे
हमें क्या करना है भाई ट्राई मारना है तो
इन्होंने स्लश एडमिन करके और ये सारी
टेक्निक्स जितने भी टेक्निक्स होते हैं वो
सारी टेक्निक्स को ट्राई कर ली तो हमने
एसवीएन को ट्राई करना है तो उसी तरीके से
हम एक-एक करके फिलहाल कर लेते हैं आप टूल
को यूज कर सकते हैं फॉर ऑटोमेशन एंड फॉर
लार्ज अमाउंट ऑफ बायपास टेक्निक्स एक साथ
यूज़ करने के लिए ये टूल्स यूज़ कर सकते
हैं 403 बायपास वाले ओके दिस आर गुड टूल्स
एक्चुअली सिंपल टूल्स है कुछ नहीं है
कीवर्ड्स को लेके और पाइथन की स्क्रिप्ट
चलाई जा रही है बस तो अब यहां पर स्लैश है
स्लश स्टार है यह सारी चीजें हम ट्राई कर
ले तो लेट्स एसवीएन के आगे स्लैश लगा के
देखते हैं व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग नहीं स्ल स्टार लगा लेते
हैं मैं आपको एक कांसेप्ट यह मैं आपको एक
माइंडसेट बता रहा हूं कि आप इस तरह का
माइंडसेट यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है स्ल परट
स् स्डट स्ल
ओके स्ल डॉट
स्ल देखो नहीं हुआ वाई पास
स्ल परसेंट ू
ए स्ल ऐसे कर दो देखो पेज नॉट फाउंड आया य
क्या बात है पेज नॉट फाउंड आ गया ओके कुछ
इस तरीके से आप ट्राई आउट कर सक जरूरी
नहीं कि बा बायपास हो ही जाएगा बट यू कैन
जस्ट ट्राई इट आउट कोईक दिक्त नहीं है आप
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें जो है आप ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं देयर कुड बी समथिंग तो यहां
पे स्ल डॉट डॉट स्ल ऐसे भी कर सकते
हो अगेन यह लॉगइन पेज ही मांग रहा है चलिए
हां दूसरा क्या चीज हम कर सकते हैं गाइस
यहां पे ये बायपास वाली टेक्निक समझ में आ
गई ये सबको समझ में आ गई ना किस तरीके से
आप ट्राई कर सकते हो 403 को बायपास करने
का एवरीवन गॉट अंडरस्टूड
अरे बता तो दिया एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड कैसे
बायपास करना है यहां पे समझ गए जल्दी बताओ
मुझे मैं देख रहा हूं चैट सेक्शन देख रहा
हूं मैं दूसरे फोन पे तो बता दो जल्दी से
यह मैं तरीका बता दिया यह करते रहना
क्योंकि इसमें काफी टाइम लगेगा तो तुम टूल
का यूज कर लेना प पाइथन वाली जो स्क्रिप्ट
आपको दिखाई थी मैंने ऐसे बहुत सारे टूल्स
आते हैं सर्च कर लेना 403 बायपास टूल गिट
हब ठीक है ओके अब यहां पे क्या कर सकते हो
तुम जब एडमिन पैनल मिल गया ना मुझे भाई तो
मेरे लिए सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग चीज क्या हो
जाती है जैसे मैं प्राइवेट को एक्सेस कर
रहा हूं
मेरे में इंटरेस्टिंग चीज हो जाती है कि
मैं यहां पे एक एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन ट्राई
करूं सिंपल सा बहुत सिंपल सा एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन है मैं आप स्कल इंजेक्शन पूरा
ट्राई कर सकते हो हालांकि हमने अभी तक
स्कल इंजेक्शन करा नहीं है बट कर लोगे
उसके बाद और भी मजा आएगा ठीक
है प्रैक्टिकल कर दिया भाई अब कितनी बार
प्रैक्टिकल करूं व प्रैक्टिकल करके बताया
बायपास टेक्निक्स ये पीडीएफ मैं आप लोगों
को दे दूंगा टेंशन आपको नहीं लेना है ये
जो पीडीएफ है ये जो पीडीएफ है गाइस आई विल
प्रोवाइड दिस पीडीएफ सो यू डोंट हैव टू
वरी अबाउट दिस ओ ओके ओके
चलिए समझ में आ
गया अरे हैकर भाई ओ हैकर भाई प्रैक्टिकली
तो किया यार क्या तुम भी यार चलो तो हम य
पर एक ट्राई करते हैं सो लेट्स गिव इट
ट्राई एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल
[संगीत]
इंजेक्शन लॉग
इन कोरी
चलिए यहां पर आ जाते हैं पोर्टस फिगर भाई
जिंदाबाद हां तो यह
रहा चलो यह बेसिक सा यूज कर लेते हैं कोई
दिक्कत
नहीं कॉपी किया यहां डाला
हमने
डन अलग-अलग चीजें यूज कर सकते हो जरूरी
नहीं है यह काम करेगा लॉगइन करते हैं नहीं
यह काम नहीं कर रहा है कोई बात नहीं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
तो आप इस तरीके से वो ट्राई कर सकते हो एल
इंजेक्शन के लॉगइन क्वेरीज को ट्राई कर
सकते हो पहली चीज तो ये है ठीक है तो यह
काफी मुझे मजा आ रहा है यह काफी चीज सही
है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग मिला भी है
प्राइवेट ओके ठीक है अब यहां पे ए
इंजेक्शन का भी अगर कुछ नहीं होता है बाय
चांस मान लो तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं भैया
हम यहां पे ना हम यहां पे क्या करेंगे हम
यहां पे अब करेंगे ट्राई बब शूट का बब शूट
का यूज करेंगे हम यहां पे करेंगे बेसिकली
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग ब्रूट फोर्सिंग करेंगे
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड ब्रूट फोर्सिंग उसके लिए
हमें एक यूजर नेम पासवर्ड की फाइल चाहिए
पता नहीं मेरे पास है कि नहीं फाइल लेट मी
सी गाइस इफ आई हैव सम फाइल यूजर पासवर्ड
[संगीत]
फाइल गेट गट बग बाउटी चेकलिस्ट चेकलिस्ट
चेकलिस्ट कोई फाइल नहीं है मेरे पास क्या
शोडाउन ए मैप ओके चीट शीट्स है यह तो ठीक
है मेरे पास फाइल यूजर पासवर्ड की
ले ओ कोई बात नहीं यूजर नेम यूजर
नेम वर्ड
लिस्ट सेक लिस्ट से उठा लेते हैं टॉप यूजर
नेम लिस्ट यहां
से ठीक है ये यूजर नेम की लिस्ट है
हालांकि ज्यादा यूजर नेम होते नहीं है
बहुत कम ही होते हैं इसमें रूट ट भी है सब
कुछ है ठीक है तो ये वाली मैं डाउनलोड कर
लेता हूं यूजर नेम ली लिस्ट ऑलरेडी
डाउनलोडेड है ओके सो लेट्स सी पासवर्ड
वाली डाउनलोडेड है क्या
पासवर्ड
पासवर्ड ड
एक्सटी नहीं पास डटी
एक्टी हा यह वाली चीज है तो लेट्स लेट्स
सी इसमें है क्या पास पास नहीं है कुछ ऐसा
कुछ नहीं है तो चलो पासवर्ड वाला भी एक
बार खोज लेते हैं यहां से यहां से कर लेते
हैं पासवर्ड वड वड लिस्ट सेक
लिस्ट 10 मिलियन पासवर्ड अरे कुछ ज्यादा
ही 10 कितने है यार अरे यह कुछ ज्यादा ही
है 10 मिलियन पासवर्ड है 10 के मोस्ट कॉमन
हा 10 के मोस्ट कॉमन 10000 पासवर्ड जो है
यह सही है हालाकि कुछ ज्यादा ही है यह भी
बट स्टिल 10000 इ वेरी वेरी हाई बेस्ट 11
यह वाली देख लेते हैं बेस्ट
11 ओके बेस्ट 11 कर
500 व
पासवर्ड 500 वाला ट्राई मार लेते ठीक है
ठीक है 500 वाला ट्राई म लेते स् पासवर्ड
500 पासवर्ड टॉप यूजरनेम य दोनों मान लेते
हैं हम क्या करते बप सूट को ओपन कर लेते
हैं लेट्स ओपन द बूट ठीक
है लोडर लेटस ओपन हा कुछ भी यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है रड एक् भी यूज कर लो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हां लेकिन अभी रक य बहुत
ज्यादा बड़ा फाइल यूज नहीं कर रहा हूं ना
मैं
काफी टाइम लगेगा ना उसमें तुम्हें दिखाने
में इसलिए नहीं यूज कर रहा वो छोटा फाइल
यूज कर रहे हैं अपन है ना गॉट इट चलिए तो
आ जाते हैं यहां पे यहां पे बब शूट को
इनेबल कर देते हैं भैया ठीक है यहां आते
इंटरसेप्ट को टारगेट इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर देते
हैं सॉरी कहां गया भाई इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन
करते हैं इस पर आ जाते हैं यहां पे डालते
हैं कुछ भी एडमिन एडमिन एंड यहां साइन इन
करके इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं रिक्वेस्ट को होप
फुली इंटरसेप्ट होगा क्या ये अरे यार
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग इंटरसेप्ट होगा ही नहीं
शायद ये मेरे खल
से
ओके हां कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है सो
सो सो सो सो सो सो सो सो इट शुड बी
इंटरसेप्टिंग बट शड इट विल नॉट क्योंकि एक
बेसिकल सिंपल सा एक जावास्क्रिप्ट वो है
तो मैं यहां
पे अ इट विल
नॉट गेट इंटरसेप्टेड मैं समझ गया
लेट्स ड न
थ अरे इंटरसेप्टर ऑन ही है
भाई तो इंटरसेप्टर न है ना यह
जावास्क्रिप्ट का व है ना तो ट्स वाई
थोड़ा सा दिक्कत मतलब वो इंटरसेप्ट नहीं
हो
पाएगा ठीक है तो जा हां हा बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल नहीं होगा यह बेसिकली
ब ठीक है कोई बात नहीं हमें दूसरी पैनल भी
मिल सकती है कोई ज्यादा टेंशन लेने वाली
बात नहीं है तो यह जावास्क्रिप्ट पॉप अप
है
तो आई थिंक इट विल नॉट बी इंटरसेप्ट राइट
तो फॉरवर्ड करते हैं देखते एक
बार
प्राइवेट
ओके या इट विल नॉट बी इंटरसेप्टेड आ आई नो
लेट्स लेट्स डन लेट्स डू अगेन अगेन
फॉरवर्ड करते देखते हमारा हमारा कुछ
इंटरसेप्शन आएगा ही नहीं मुझे पता है
क्योंकि ठीक है इंटरसेप्ट नहीं होगा ये
ओबवियसली मैं कंट्रोल य करके एक बार सोर्स
कोड देख लेता
हूं इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते
हैं सोर्स कोड भी इसका नहीं आएगा ओबवियसली
क्योंकि जावा जावास्क्रिप्ट पॉप अप है
ओबवियसली तो दिस इज नॉट डन बट ठीक है यहां
पे आप आ मैं आपको एक मेथड सिखा रहा हूं
आपको यस यस यस यस वो मेथड जीी सिखा रहा
हूं यहां पे सोर्स कोड भी आपको नहीं
मिलेगा सिंपल सा आपको ब्रूट फोर्स करने का
है अभी अभी अपन को दूसरा जब ब्रूट फोर्स
कोई पेज मिलता है तो उसपे भी हम ट्राई
करेंगे ठीक है कुछ नहीं है सोर्स पेज प
भाई कुछ नहीं मिलेगा ठीक है ब्रो जस्ट
वाचिंग यू बिकॉज यू आर क्वाइट हैंडसम देन
अदर क्रिएटर एंड यर वे ऑफ टीचिंग इ
फैमिलियर अरे भाई
हैंड्स अरे भाई यह बंदा मुझे यह बंदा
इसलिए देख रहा है क्योंकि मैं हैंडसम हूं
इसलिए वाह यार क्या बात है ताली भाई
ताली बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया गुड
थैंक यू फॉर द कंप्लीमेंट है
ना ओके चलिए तो आप इस पर कैसे ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं आपको समझ में आ ही गया होगा
समझ में आपको अभी भी आ रहा होगा यू कैन
जस्ट ट्राई इट आउट हियर डिफरेंट डिफरेंट
वेरियस थिंग्स य हमने भाई यहां हमने ये
किया तो हमें यहां प कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास हमें
यहां पर मिला नहीं है मैं एक काम करता हूं
ना मेरे को एक वर्डलिस्ट चाहिए डायरेक्टरी
बूट डायरेक्टरी वाली लेट्स फाइंड लेट्स
डाउनलोड दैट डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स वाली
सो
डायरेक्टरी सेक लिस्ट पर चलते हैं लेटस गो
टू सेक
लिस्ट सर आपके डिप्लोमा इन साइबर स ऑनलाइन
कोर्स है क्या हा जी ऑनलाइन डिप्लोमा
साइबर सिक्योरिटी की कोर्स की अनाउंसमेंट
आएगी बहुत जल्द तो य फजिंग में चल फजिंग
में चल फजिंग में होगा क्या आई थ डिस्कवरी
में होगी शायद 403 फजिंग है य पर
हां जी डिस्कवरी में ही होगा यह वेब
कंटेंट के अंदर में शायद वेब कंटेंट यह
रहा कॉमन बैक डोस बैक डोस बैक डोस कॉमन
कॉमन डिफॉल्ट हा यह रहा डिफॉल्ट वेब
डायरेक्टरी कॉमन ड डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट है
यहां पर ठीक है अच्छी बात है र सर्च सर्च
वाली य कितने इसमें कितने डायरेक्टरी
लिस्ट है
1299 क्या बात है 12000 लिस्ट है बहुत है
यार 12000 तो बहुत बड़ी लिस्ट हो गई चलो
5000 के जग 12000 जो है वो मिल रहे है
रेफ्ट वाली बहुत अच्छी होती है वैसे तो यू
कैन यूज दिस आल्सो राफ्ट जो डायरेक्टरी है
तो हम इसको यूज कर सकते हैं बेलाल ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है चलो डीर सर्च वाली ले लेते
हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं र सर्च वाली को
डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
. इसको हम यूज करेंगे अपने मशीन के अंदर
में तो उसको मैं अपलोड कर देता हूं व वाली
जो अ डाउनलोड किया यहां से अपलोड कहां गया
अपलोड कर देता हूं डाउनलोड्स पे आ जाओ .
अपलोड कर देता हूं पाथ
पे सो इट्स गेटिंग अपलोडेड एंड आई थिंक
अपलोड हो चुका है
ये सो एलएस करके देख लेते हैं अपलोड हुआ
कि नहीं डी सर्च हां आ चुका है यहां पे
कडी
search.com य पर जो हम यूज करेंगे ना ड
यूज करेंगे क्योंकि इसमें काफी ज्यादा
कीवर्ड्स है वर्ड लिस्ट है मैं 200 को यूज
करूंगा ओनली 43 पर भी जाने का कोई मतलब है
नहीं क्योंकि बायपास अभी नहीं हो रहा है
तो लेट्स सी व्ट
इनिंग लेट्स सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग
समथिंग हियर चांसेस आर लेस बट स्टिल वी
हैव टू गिव ट्राई फॉर एवरीथिंग जितना हो
सकता है हमें ट्राई तो करना ही
है लिनिक्स प जो होती है डिफॉल्ट जितनी भी
होती है सारी होती है भाई डिफॉल्ट जो जो
है वो सब मिल जाएंगे लिनिक्स प वर्ड लिस्ट
फोल्डर के अंदर में
आपको ठीक
है सर कितने ईयर का डिप्लोमा डिप्लोमा इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी सिक्स मंथ्स का हमारा
ऑनलाइन इंटेंस ंग ट्रेनिंग प्रोग्राम होता
है डिप्लोमा का ठीक है
सर मैं काली ही आपके पाछ साल कल ही आपके
पाछ साल पुराना वीडियो देख देखा हूं एकदम
नेक्स्ट लेवल पढ़ाते हो आप धन्यवाद
भाई सवाल
[संगीत]
सा कुछ बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं हम मूव ऑन
करते हैं यहां से हटते
हैं लेट्स गो टू सम
अदर चीज अब देखो robot.txt में और क्या और
कैसे आप फाइंड कर सकते हो robot.txt वाली
चीज
google.duo db.com यह बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
तरीका है मैं इसको अ इसको हटा देता हूं
एंगेजमेंट इससे भी हम उठा लेंगे r इनो
वाले में तो और कुछ है नहीं यहां पे
इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ ऐसा और भी प्रोग्राम्स है
यहां पे कोई बात नहीं देख लेंगे और यहां
google.org का यूज करके robot.txt वाली
वेबसाइट्स फाइंड करो ठीक है अब देखो कोई
एजुकेशनल वेबसाइट है वहां की robot.txt
आपको फाइंड करनी है यह वाली डॉक ली यह
वाली यहां पे पेस्ट मारा एंड एंटर अब देखो
यहां पे कुछ मिलता है तो भाई अ इक्स ऑफ
robot.txt फाइल अवेलेबल है यहां पे चलिए
ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां पे डिस अलाउ में
इनकमिंग पय बी एफटीपी तो यह पीयू बी
फोल्डर को डिस अलाउ किया पता नहीं
एक्सेसिबल है कि नहीं पीयू बी करके ओपन कर
लेते हैं देखते हैं क्या है कुछ है कि
नहीं अंदर में ओ भाई ये पूरी की पूरी
डायरेक्टरी इंडेक्सिंग है यहां पे पीयू बी
तो यह वेबसाइट की पूरी की पूरी डायरेक्टरी
इंडेक्सिंग पब्लिक वाली डायरेक्टरी जो है
इंडेक्स जो वो यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल
चुकी है तो यहां पर कुछ चीजें है एन क्या
है ये है क्या यूपी 2010 ये क्या
है पिक्चर्स व्ट टाइप ऑफ पिक्चर्स इ कुछ
पिक्चर्स है ये आई डोंट नो कि क्या
पिक्चर्स हैय लेट्स सी सो यह कुछ पिक्चर्स
है जो यहां पर इनके मिल रहे
हैं लेट्स ओपन दिस पिक्चर्स बस नॉर्मल
पिक्चर्स ही हो यहां पे फीनिक्स अच्छा
इनके कुछ अपने पिक्चर सचस
है बढ़िया
है बढ़िया तो इस तर की चीज मिल ही है अब य
पर कुछ और कोई चीज देखो यार प्रिंस्टन
यूनिवर्सिटी का कुछ है शायद प्रिंस्टन का
रोब में कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीज नहीं है ब य
पर कुछ इंडिया का है क्या
कुछ लेट
ट बर्कले
बर्कली के
हैं चलो बहुत सारे यहां पर वैसे बट फिलहाल
हम अभी इस पर जाते हैं इस पर देखते हैं अब
यहां पे अब यहां प देखो इन यरल डब्लू
कंटेंट अपलोड्स अपलोड वाली यरल इन यर डिस
अला फाटा यह वाली चीज हो तब वो मुझे
रिजल्ट्स मिले फाटा एकटी वाली तो यह भी
इंटरेस्टिंग कीवर्ड मुझे लग रहा है इसको
सर्च करते देखते हैं क्या मिलता है मुझे
de.com कारो मुझे मिला वायर का मुझे मिला
चलो गीक वायर क्या है देखते हैं इस पर
क्या है क्या बात है भाई यह डिस अलाउड है
लिस्ट मेंबर्स
के स्लश मेंबर्स आर अलाउड मेंबर्स आर डिस
अलाउड देखते हैं इस पर क्या है भाई
मेंबर्स वाले प कुछ है
क्या मेंबर
यूनिवर्स कुछ कुछ खास है नहीं बाकी ये
अपलोड यहां पर 2027 फ्यूचर ये क्या कर रहे
हैं
ये ये फ्यूचर में रहते हैं क्या भाई ये
2023 24 के बाद 25 का अपलोड कैसे कर दिया
भाई 2627 भाई यह कोई फ्यूचर से आया हुआ
कंपनी है गक वायर यह लोग ना फ्यूचर में
ऑपरेट कर रहे हैं एंड अभी इन्होंने यह
फ्यूचर में ऑलरेडी या तो जा चुके हैं शायद
मेरे ख्याल से मुझे ऐसा लग रहा है सो दे
आर ऑलरेडी इन फ्यूचर गाइस तभी इन्होंने
डब्ल्यूपी अपलोड्स में ना 2027 डाल दिया
है तो वी वड लव टू सी दिस पाथ 24 वाला
पहले देखते हैं फ्यूचर का तो क्या ही
देखें कहीं कुछ
चलो ओबवियसली फॉर बिडेन है य कोई बात
नहीं चल ओ मुझे लगा कि बायपास हो गया कोई
बात नहीं बायपास तो नहीं हुआ चलो ठीक है
चलता है यहां पर कोई दिक्कत नहीं यार ब
नॉट फाउंड वाली आ रही है चलिए अच्छी बात
है
फ्यूचर में यह लोग जा रहे थे अभी चलो और
भी है बहुत सारे यहां पर ड्रेक्स डक्स कोड
कॉ अब देखो यहां पर ओ हो हो भाई भाई
साहब यह देखो इनके डिस अलाउड में यहां पे
एसबीएन आईडिया टीजी
जड प डाउनलोड एरर्स इंक्लूड लि पीकेजी
इंफो शल वेर एआई पीएपी यह सारे डिस अलाउड
है यह बहुत बढ़िया चीज है डिस अलाउड में
कस्टम
कस्टमर अकाउंट अच्छा लॉग इन ठीक है फायर
चेक आउट कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग इसमें मुझे दिख
तो नहीं रहा बट देख लेते हैं पीप इफ
पीएचपी ठीक है डब्ल्यूपी डब्ल्यूपी एडमिन
यह वाली इनका है भाई यह है इनका
पेज एडमिन पेज डब्ल्यूपी डब्ल्यूपी
एडमिन जो कि इन्होंने फॉर बिडेन कर रखा
है कोई बात नहीं यार फॉर बिन कर रखा है तो
हम क्या कर कर सकते हैं मैंने आपको कुछ
बोला थोड़ी फॉर बिन करके रखा है
तो ठीक है मैं एक बार और डॉट लगा देता हूं
मैं तो कुछ भी लगा के ट्राई मारता रहूंगा
आप फॉर बिन करो कीप न ट्रा 403 403 टूल
यूज कर लेना भाई पेजी नॉट फाउंड कुछ मिला
पजना नॉट फाउंड मतलब पेजय नहीं है कोई बात
नहीं यार डब्ल्यूपी कंटेंट अवेलेबल है
क्या स्लाइस डब्लू पी कंटेंट
इज
अवेलेबल क्या बात है बेचार का पेज अवेलेबल
नहीं है यह सब तो ठीक है भाई डिस अलाउ में
बहुत कुछ डिस अलाउ कर रखा है इन्होंने तो
मेरे को चाहिए एस ये
वाला एसबीएन
वाला फॉरन है फॉरन करके रखा है इन्होने
चलो अच्छी बात है ट्स ग्रेट कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है तो यहां पे मुझे ये चीज मिल गई अब
यहां पे स एटी एफटीपी वाली ईमेल्स वाली
सीएमएस वाली अच्छा सीएमएस के व है रो
इंडेक्स ऑफ सिंपल सा यहां पर है पीएचपी
माय एडमिन अच्छी साइट गवर्नमेंट वाली साइड
य सही है या यह देखो गवर्नमेंट वाली है य
यरल गवर्नमेंट वाली य डॉक है यू कैन जस्ट
विजिट
इट य किसका है एन आई एच
गवर्नमेंट एल ए एनल गवर्नमेंट
एल एनल गवर्नमेंट ठीक है पीपीपीएल
गवर्नमेंट ई
पीजीओ आ कुछ नहीं है क्या अपने गवर्नमेंट
का कुछ ऐसा है नहीं शायद डीओ
एज ठीक है
[संगीत]
आरजीवी चलो इसको देखते आरज क्या है य सो
लेट्स ओपन यहां पर देखो यहां पर डिसला में
स्ल प्रोफाइल है वेबड कन्फ है ओके वेब डॉट
कन्फ इसको इंटरेस्टिंग वेब डॉट कॉफिगुड्डा
नथिंग देयर नथिंग देयर नथिंग देयर कुछ खास
है नहीं यहां पे ना चलो अब यहां पे देख
लेते हैं फाइ टाइप डटी एक्सटी दिस अलाउ
देख लेते हैं यहां पे कुछ कुछ मिले
इंटरेस्टिंग टी एक्सटी फाइल वाली टीस वाली
देख लेते हैं शायद यहां कुछ मिल
जाएगी क्या बात है भाई टी एक्सटी ये क्या
है गवर्मेंट ड
यके आ जाओ आ जाओ आ जाओ आ
जाओ डिस अलाउ डिसला ठीक है डिसला
डिसला वेब
कॉन्फो नो डायरेक्टर ऑटोलोड पीएचपी ओके इ
पप
एडमिन एडमिन वाली है यह सो लेट्स गिव इट
ट्राई ओके 403 आ रहा है य बायपास करने
बायपास करने की ट्राई कीजिएगा गा बायपास
करके आप बहुत कुछ कर सकते याद रखिएगा बात
मेरे दिमाग में अपने फिट कर लीजिए भाई
ऑटोलोड पीएचपी है कुछ खास आएगा नहीं अपडेट
पीएचपी नथिंग ऑटोलोड कुछ खास है नहीं
नॉट ओके आईबीएम का है भाई आईबीएम आईबीएम
आईबीएम आईबीएम में क्या है
भाई व्ट्स देयर इन आईबीएम होगा बहुत कुछ
होगा ibm.com
पे निफ्ट डट ए निफ्ट क्या है नेशनल
इंस्टिट्यूट ऑफ फैशन टेक्नोलॉजी वाली है
क्या ये निफ्ट ड एड आ यह कौन सी है भाई
एईटी वाली है क्या नेशनल इंस्टिट्यूट ऑफ
फैशन
टेक्नोलॉजी या कुछ और है हां यह तो वही है
यार अच्छा यह इंडिया वाली है मतलब इंडिया
की है ओबवियसली सो एनईएफटी के मिले हमें
डिसला में वेब डट कॉन्ग है आई होप
इन्होंने भी फॉर बिडेन करके रखा होगा मेरे
ख्याल से लेटस लेट गव इट
ट्राई भाई तो गजब भगा ही दिया पूरा चलो
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
[संगीत]
अ कुछ हमें मिल रहा है क्या कमेंट रिप्लाई
फिल्टर टिप्स लॉग आउट लॉग इन लॉग इन लॉग
इन कुछ खास तो मिला नहीं स्लश एडमिन वाली
चीज है तो एडमिन पैनल पता नहीं शायद
एक्सेसिबल है कि नहीं देख लेते हैं सो यू
आर नॉट ऑथराइज्ड टू एक्सेस दिस पेज अरे
ठीक है भाई तो स्लैश लगाओ एक बार डाउनलोड
होगा कुछ नॉट ऑथराइज्ड तो एक बार स्लैश के
बाद डॉट लगाओ यू आर नॉट ऑथराइज्ड
अच्छा डॉट स्लश लगाओ
404 आएगा क्या ऐसे डिनाइड ठीक है स्लस के
बाद
परसेंटेज ट
एफ न फ चलो ठीक है कोई ना चलता है इतना तो
निफ्ट का है भाई ले यूनिवर्सिटी ल
यूनिवर्सिटी है कुछ ऐसे कुछ करके ल
यूनिवर्सिटी इन्होने डिसला में क्या डाला
भाई हां यह डाला है ये अच्छी चीज डाली है
ये खुल जा भाई खुल जा सिम सिम तुम खुलजा
सिम सिम में क्या है स्ल एडमिन है पहले तो
यहां कुछ चीजें है मुझे जो दिख रही है सो
मैं तो ट्राई करना चाहूंगा आप भी ट्राई
करेंगे
क्या अच्छ एक्सेस डिनाइड
है यहां पर इंस्टॉल मायटी एक्सटी करके एक
पाथ है जो कि मुझे थोड़ा इंटरेस्टिंग लग
रहा है अगर ओपन हो जाए
तो डाल दिया है लोगों
ने मेंटेनर्स है यहां
परने डाल दिया नहीं तो अभी बढ़िया से इनकी
ल जाती है अभी रो ऑन टू
टेक्स्ट डिस अलाउ अटैचमेंट आईडी प्लगइन
डब्ल्यूपी एडमिन ठीक है भाई डब्ल्यूपी
एडमिन क्या तुम करोगे यार उसको बचा के
क्या ही फायदा है हटाओ
इसको सो इस तरीके से
अप्रोचेबल यही है और ब्रूट फोर्स वाली
टेक्निक में अभी ट्राई करते हैं ब्रूट
फोर्स वाली टेक्निक बहुत जरूरी है तो
एडमिन का लेट्स ट्रा एडमिन
पैनल क्याय भाई फाइ
कुछ बढ़िया मिलो
यार चलो लाइव पे एक बार चल देते हैं
पीएचपी मा एडमन रोसी ओके ओके ओके ओके ओ
ओके ओके एडमिन का कुछ है क्या सीन अ
[संगीत]
एडमिन पप मा एडमिन नहीं कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास
सीन है नहीं चलिए यहां पे एक प्रोग्राम
लेते हैं चूज करते हैं जो भी सी ऑल बग
बाउटी प्रोग्राम इस पर चलते हैं एंड यहां
बक्र प चलते हैं कोई एक बैकग्राउंड प कोई
एक चीज लेते हैं स्क्वायर क्या है भाई
स्क्वायर ये स्ड कॉ है क्या ये लेट्स चेक
स्कोप एंड रिवार्ड्स
s.com क्या बात है भाई तुम लोग कहां रहते
हो यार इतना तुम लोगों को मैं खोजता हूं
फिर भी मिलते नहीं हो s.com प चलते हैं
स्क्वायर स्क्वा up.com प चलते
हैं इसको भी ओपन करते
हैं क्या दोनों एक ही है क्या यार अरे भाई
क्यों दोनों वही है तो स्ल रोबोट डटी
एकटी लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग
अच्छा हां जी यहां पे है
भाई फी ऑफ डिप्लोमा इ 00 टू बी गिवन इन
फोर मंथली इंस्टॉलमेंट फफ 5000 ईच ट्स इट
और अगर आप वन टाइम करते हैं तो 15000
ठीक है 5000 का इस्टेंट डिस्काउंट चलो
यहां पर अलाउड में तो ये चलो ठीक है डिस
अलाउ में य पर डिटेक्ट कंट्री ट्रैकिंग
अपॉइंटमेंट मैप बुक ठीक है कैपिटल कंजूमर
इनवॉइस मर्चेंट यह क्या है भाई यह कुछ खुल
जाए ना तो मजा आ जाए वही बात है खलनी
चाहिए रय ओपन नहीं होते हैं सब सब लोगों
ने वो करके रखा हुआ
है नहीं नहीं
नहीं नहीं नहीं ऐसे कैसे करोगे
भाई बायर एपीआई लॉग आउट रिटर्न लॉग इन
पासवर्ड व्ट इज दिस पेन वॉइस पासवर्ड भी
है
कुछ क्या बात है स्क्वायर अप स्ल पासवर्ड
पर साइन इन है क्या साइन इन है भाई कौन
साइन इन है अच्छा रिसेट पासवर्ड है क्या
कोई बात नहीं बिल पे अकेडमी अकेडमी सेल
नाउ सेल नाउ प क्या है यार
सेल एंड हाई फन नाउ व्ट्स
हियर एरर कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं या
भाई अ मुझे कोई इंटरेस्टिंग अगर पाथ मिलता
है ना उसम हम फजिंग कर सकते याद रखिएगा तो
फजिंग के लिए ना मेरे पास इसमें कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग पाथ आपको दिख रहा है क्या
बताइए
मुझे हेल्प
सब्सक्रिप्शन साइन अप टोकन पासवर्ड पे
इनवॉइस कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास तो मुझे दिख नहीं
रहा पेन वॉइस
पे ओके हाय हाय हेलो हेलो
भाई बिफोर यू गो लाइव सर रिसर्च मोर सो यू
सो ओनली प्रोडक्टिव कंटेंट इट मींस यू आर
वेस्टिंग योर टाइम एंड आस तो भाई निकल लो
भाई मीर भाई तुम निकलो यहां से तुम्हारा
टाइम वेस्ट हो रहा है चलो भग लो जल्दी से
भग लो पे इनवॉइस यहां पर आते हैं देखते
हैं क्या है यहां
पे पे इव तुम जैसों के लिए नहीं है भाई य
सीरीज पे इन वॉयसेस प मुझे कुछ ऐसा तो मिल
नहीं रहा नो पेज ज कमिंग हियर बट स्टिल वी
कैन गिव इट अ ट्राई ऑन
आवर यहां पे डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स करने
के लिए तो वी विल गिव इट ब्रूट फोर्स
ट्राई ओके तो चलिए यहां पर चलते हैं डाय
सर्च में चलते हैं अब यहां पे हमें कुछ
चीजें मिल सकती है क्या बात है
भाई इनवॉइस
स्ल फज एंड लेट्स सी लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग ये क्या हुआ
भाई नथिंग ग गट नथिंग य स्क्वायर अप कितने
मिले मुझे क्या मिला डायटी एक्टी किया
पूरा तो ओपन पूरा किया ही नहीं यार एरर
एरर एरर क्यों एरर एफफ फ ए य सब कुछ सही
था इनवॉइस
स्लश फज एंड यहां
पे ठीक है हां रे मुझे पता है यार बहुत
फालतू लोग होते हैं आई
नो आई नो अरे वो हेट्स लोग होते हैं ना
जिनकी बैंड बजी पड़ी रहती है मुझे पता है
वो वही लोग है आई नो आई नो ऑलरेडी यार आई
नो ऑलरेडी ये लोग वही बात वही लोग है
जिनकी बैंड बजी पड़ी है बग बाउंट की कोर्स
से क्योंकि ये लो और देखो कितना प्यार से
बोल रहा है ये भी देखो बात भी समझने वाली
बात है ना क्योंकि मैं तो इंसान को उसकी
बातों से समझ जाता हूं सीधी सी बात है
इतना तो एक्सपीरियंस हो ही चुका है देखो
प्यार से बोला है कितना ताकि मैं अब उल्टा
मान लो गलत तरीके से बोलेगा तो वैसे ही
सुन लेगा तो प्यार से बोल रहा है अच्छे से
और बोल भी रहा है तो वैसे लोगों को निकाल
दो खत्म डोंट गिव देम वैल्यूज और अटेंशन
ओके सीधा क्या करो टाइम आउट परमानेंट कर
दो बात खत्म राइट
चलिए लव यू फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान इनकी दुकान
बंद होगी फिर थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू सर
कैरी ऑन ये लोग टर्स हैं पेड क्लास लेके आ
जाते हैं सिखा नहीं होता है पे हां
बिल्कुल सही बात है बिल्कुल सही बात है ये
लोग फालतू लोग हैं ब्रेव ब गेमिंग हां यार
कुछ ज्यादा ही फालतू है लोग तो क्या ही कर
सकते हैं कोई ना चलो देखो जहा जहां यार
सपोर्टर्स होते हैं ना वहा हेटर तो होते
ही है तो उतना लेके चलना पड़ता है अपने को
ठीक
है अब देखो इसको इसकी मैं बंड बजा देता
हूं पुट यूजर इन टाइम आउट पहली बात तो
टाइम आउट प इसको भेजते हैं 24 घंटे के लिए
और दूसरी बात ना इसको क्या कर देते हैं ना
इस बंदे को हाइड फ्रॉम यूजर न दिस चैनल
इसको हाइड ही कर देते पूरे चैनल से
गायब धन्यवाद चलिए तो यहां पर हम डायरेक्ट
ब्रूट फोर्स भी कर सकते हैं वी कैन गो फॉर
द डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्सिंग आल्सो बट हमें
कुछ खास यहां पर मिला तो नहीं है ब ठीक है
चलता है इतना कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कुछ वो
चीज स्क्वायर पे हमने देख लिया नाउ लेट्स
स लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स सी रिसेंट
प्रोग्राम जॉइने बल में कुछ है क्या
बी अथॉरिटी क्या भाई यहां
पर बग बाउटी बग बाउंट बग
बांटी इंटरम रोबर्ट ल स्ट्रेट कोई भी
इंटरेस्टिंग करते है ना यार थैंक यू थैंक
यू रिपोर्ट कर देंगे ना सिंपल जैसे
रिपोर्ट अच्छा मैं टेंशन मत लो या
मैं तुम लोगों का रिपोर्ट राइटिंग का एक
डेडिकेटेड वीडियो बना दूंगा ठीक है मैं
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग पर डेडिकेटेड वीडियो बना
दूंगा ठीक है
भाई यू आर इगनोरिंग माय कमेंट्स इग्नोर
नहीं कर रहा भाई यार मैं इधर थोड़ा बिजी
हूं इग्नोर क्या
करूंगा चलिए एम पल यह वाली चीज है अच्छा
एक बार इसको वो करते हैं डेट्स पर करते
हैं स्टार्टड एंड टारगेट कैटेगरी पर चलते
हैं टारगेट कैटेगरी स्कोप में चलते हैं
रिवर्ड पर चलते हैं
चलो डेट्स पर मैं क्या करता हूं ना
स्टार्ट डेट करता हूं मैं अप्रल नहीं 2022
का कोई प्रोग्राम निकालते हैं 2022
का एक
अप्रैल देखते हैं कुछ आता है कि नहीं ठीक
है मुझे मिला यहां
पे लेट्स सी टाइडल ओपन ए आई टाइडल म्यूजिक
स्ट्रीमिंग है ये टाइडल इसको उठा लेते
हैं या आई विल ब्रिंग दैट थथ 2.0 वाली जो
है य एडवांस वाले में आएंगे ठीक है तो
टेंशन नहीं लेने का चलिए यहां पर बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मुझे मिल रही है सो वी
आर गेटिंग टाइडल कॉ लेट्स गिव इट अ ट्राई
क ओपन कर लो इसको जितनी आ रही है सब ओपन
करो डब्लू आईपी म्यूजिक इसको भी ओपन
करेंगे भाई अरे क्या हुआ यह डब्लू आईपी
म्यूजिक इसको भी ओपन कर
लो टन
ट इसको भी ओपन कर लिया अच्छा यह दोनों सेम
टाइटल ड कॉ ही है भाई कोई बात नहीं इसको
हटा दो
टीडीएल ड एस व्ट इ दिस दे से दिस इ
वेबसाइट
वेबसाइट या उसी प डायरेक्ट कर देगा टाइडल
प अच्छा यह उसी पर डायरेक्ट कर रहा है
मुझे लग ही रहा था
ए ओके डॉट एफ आई इ दिस ल्स रीडायरेक्टिंग
लेट्स सी इट रीडायरेक्टिंग टू सम वेर एल्स
तो चलिए टाइटल प आ जाते हैं य यहां पर
इनका रोबोट डटी एक्स देख लेते
हैं ठीक है य डिस अलाउड में डिस अलाउड डिस
अलाउड डिसला कुछ है ही नहीं
यार कुछ नहीं अच्छा यहां है टर्म स्कैन
आर्टिस्ट सबमिशन व्हाट इज दिस आर्टिस्ट
सबमिशन
लेट्स लेट्स फाइंड आउट आर्टिस्ट सबमिशन
क्या है भाई
ये ओके थैंक यू फॉर इंटरेस्ट इन टाइटल
राइजिंग प्लीज एंटर इंफॉर्मेशन रिसीव
अपडेट्स टू बी अच्छा यहां प कुछ अपडेट्स
है यहां डाल सकते यहां पे एक्सस के लिए
ट्राई मार सकते हो भाई ठीक है सिंपल है
एक्सेसेस के लिए जब ऐसी चीजें मिल जाए
तुम्हें पेज जो जनरली नहीं है अवेलेबल अब
यहां ट्राई मार लो ना मैंने डाला यहां पे
अ फर्स्ट नेम में डाला
[संगीत]
मिस्टर मिस्टर परफेक्ट यह डाल दिया मैंने
ठीक है व्हाट इज डू यू नेम व्हाट नेम डू
यू गो बाय एज एन
आर्टिस्ट लीव एमटी इफ नॉट एप्लीकेबल ठीक
है तो मैं यहां पे एक यार डाल ही देता हूं
कोई सा भी एक एक्सस के पेलोड उठा लेते हैं
ठीक है चलो एक्सस के पेलोड हमने उठा लिया
यहां से एंड वी आर आईएमजी एसआरसी जो पेलोड
है ना उसी को उठा लेते
हैं ऑन एरर उठा लेते हैं ठीक है ऑन एरर ऑन
एरर ऑन एरर कहां गया
भाई चलो सो वी आर यूजिंग दिस पेलोड एंड आई
एम गोइंग टू डू यहां पेलो डालते हैं
मिस्टर परफेक्ट फर्स्ट नेम में पेलो डालते
हैं लास्ट नेम में पेलो डालते हैं वेयर
कैन यू रीच वेर यू कैन वी कैन रीच यू तो
मैं डाल देता हूं हेलो @ हेलोड कॉ इस पर
रीच आउट करो भाई च कंट्री डू यू रि साइड
इन तो इंडिया एंड डिस्क्राइब रोल तो मैं
एक मैनेजर हूं हाउ ड यू इंटरेस्टेड इन
इसमें कुछ नहीं डालते चलो इसमें भी डाल
देते हैं ना क्या दिक्कत है प्लीज सबमिट अ
लिंक टाइटल लास्ट ट्रैक एल कु वुड यू लाइक
टू कंसीडर यस इज एनीथिंग आ वड लाइक टूम यस
अगेन डैश डैश सबमिट एंड ट्राई कर सकते हैं
ट्राई कर सकते हैं कुछ मिलता है तो हमें
बट ऐसा कुछ खास हमें यहां पे मिला नहीं है
राइट तो दिस इज़ द सेम थिंग अब मैनेज
अकाउंट पे चलते हैं यहां पे लॉगिन पैनल है
यहां पे
कुछ ओके नथिंग
एल्स तो हमें कुछ खास वहां मिला नहीं था
तो इस तरीके से हमें क्या करना है वी हैव
टू ट्राई इट आउट विद डिफरेंट डिफरेंट
पेलोड्स ठीक है डिफरेंट डिफरेंट चीजें
ट्राई आउट करनी है भाई एक ही चीज तो है
नहीं यार s.com प चलते हैं यहां पे देखते
हैं स्ल robot.txt
ठीक है तो कुछ नहीं है साइड मैप है और कुछ
नहीं है तो बेसिकली हम क्या एक्चुअली कर
पा रहे हैं यह देखिए हम लोग ने क्या हम
क्या कर रहे हैं robots.txt के थ्रू व्हाट
वी आर गोइंग व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू
व्हाट वी आर डूइंग फाइंडिंग
हिडन पेजेस च मे
कंटेंस मे कंटेंस
सेंसिटिव डाटास ठीक है दूसरा हम क्या कर
सकते हैं ब्रूट
फोर्स इफ वी फाउंड लॉग इन
पैनल वी कैन ट्राई टू ब्रूट फोर्स यूजिंग
बॉब सूट या जैसे भी करो आप व है वी
कैन ट्राई फॉर एक्सेसेस ऑन वेरियस
पेजेस फाउंड इन डिस
अलाउड डिस अलाउड लिस्ट ठीक है यह ट्राई आप
कर सकते हो अलग अलग पेजेस पर मतलब आप वो
कर सकते हो डिस अलाउड पेजेस पर चार में
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
अलाउड पेजेस टू फाइंड
सेंसिटिव डायरेक्टरीज यह सारे काम आप कर
सकते हैं ठीक है
भाई समझ में आ
गया ओके तो यह सारी चीजें बस आप क्या कर
सकते हो यह सारी चीजें आप टी के अंदर में
कर सकते हो जो हम बेसिकली कर रहे हैं तो
ये आपके एक्सप्लोरेशन पार्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन
का ये पार्ट है बेसिकली मैंने आपको पहले
ही बताया है माइंडसेट कैसा डेवलप करना जो
चीज मैं य सिखाऊ उस चीज को एक्सप्लोर करो
जाक और देखो क्या क्या चीज और पॉसिबल है
क्या क्या चीज हम और कर सकते हैं बिकॉज
देर आर मेनी थिंग्स दैट वी कैन डू
एक्चुअली दे लट ऑफ लट ऑफ थंग्स ठीक है तो
चलिए यह हो गया कोई एक ओपन बग बाउंट से ही
निकालते हैं प्रोग्राम यहां से निकालते
हैं चलिए मैं क्या करता
हूं इसमें कुछ शॉटिंग है क्या सर्च बाय
शटिंग वगर कुछ नहीं
है 40 पेज पर डायरेक्ट जा सकते हैं क्या फ
40 पेज पर नहीं जा सकते क्या अच्छा 40 पेज
प आ गए हा तो य चलते यो विंडो क यह कौन सी
वेबसाइट है भाई वेबसाइट क्या
क ठीक
है लेट गव इट ट्राई यो विंडो क इटस
वेबसाइट यो विंडो पता नहीं एक्सेसिबल है
भी कि नहीं
अभी खुलेगा नहीं
स्क्रीन शॉट लेनी है भाई लो स्लीन शॉट यह
लो क्लीन शॉट टेक द स्लीन शॉट जिनको भी
लेनी है भाई ई होई टेक द स्क्रीनशॉट गाइस
हरी अप गाइस हरी अप हरी अप गा टेक द
स्क्रीनशॉट आ
ग्रेट बेचारा चल नहीं रहा गड में ट्रेडर
यह देख लेते गड में ट्रेडर कौन सा है
भाई
थन अरे यह बहुत पुराने लग रहे मुझे
तो स्पाइडर ऑनलाइन क्या है ये
यार य हॉर्स
मैन कुछ ज्यादा ही पुराना मैंने कर दिया
है 36 36 पर चलते हैं
लेट्स गो टू 36
पेज लेट्स ट्राई टू ओपन
सम
इनफॉर्म अरे भाई वेब पेज तो ओपन हो जा यह
यही नहीं ओपन हो रही है हद है भाई डिसेबल
करो बब सूट को
यार ले डिबल बूट लेट्स ट्राई
ना ब भी ओपन डिबल नहीं हो रही य क्या हो
रहा है
ट हैपनिंग
गा लेलिया क्लीन बहुत बढ़िया गेटवे टाइम
आउट ओपन बक बांटी डाउन हो गया वाह यार वाह
वाह वाह क्या बात है भाई क्लाउड वर्क कर
रहा है ओपन बग बांटी डाउन है तो वेबसाइट
नहीं खुल रही है यह क्या है डटा टा टेबल
वनिंग टेबल आईडी बग बाउंटीज एजेक्स एरर
क्या बात है यार एंड फॉर मोर इंफॉर्मेशन
विजिट द डेटा डेवल नॉट नेट अरे भाई
तुम्हारी तो यार ओपन बग बाउंट ही डाउन हो
गई भाई इस पर कोई अटैक कर दिया
क्या गलत बात है यार गलत बात है ओपन बक
बाउंडी को ऐसे नहीं करना चाहिए अच्छा तो
टाइडल फडल तो हटा दो यहां पर टाइडल डल से
तो कुछ है नहीं लेना देना य प अपने को बरा
चलो हैकर पर चलो इंगेजमेंट पर चलो अब ओपन
हो रहा है
भाई हा जी तो अब ओपन कर लेते हैं टा किंगर
कीडर कॉ कारा डायरेक्ट कॉ जो भी
है हा जी अब ओपन हो रही है यह अच्छी बात
है नाउ इट्स
ओपनिंग चलो यहां से एक वेबसाइट न एक
टारगेट अपना ओपन करले
लेटस ओपन दिस टारगेट गा लेट्स ओपन दिस
टारगेट ओके लेट्स ओपन दिस टारगेट आल्सो
मल्टीपल टारगेट ओपन कर रहे हम गा ताकि हम
कुछ देख पाए करके यहां पर कि कुछ कर पाते
नहीं कुछ आता है कि नहीं हमें तो यहां
हमें मिला यहां हम रोबोट ड एक्टी ऐड
करेंगे लेट्स ओपन इट क्या है भाई डिस अलाउ
कुछ नहीं है एंड योस ब्लॉक है कुछ भी नहीं
है स्टार्ट यो ब्लॉक एंड यो ब्लॉक कुछ भी
नहीं है चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां इस पर
करते हैं स् रोबोट डटी एक्टी बड़ी बब ओ
डिस अलाउ में क्या है भाई ब्रोकर सेलेक्ट
डिपोर्ट ऑर्डर ऑर्डर कंप्लीट पोजीशन ऑप्शन
अकेडमी कोर्स अरे ये क्या है बट 000 वाली
चीज
व्ट इज दिस 000 दो बार अच्छा कुछ खास नहीं
य पर इनका यहां देख लेते हैं स् रोबोटी
एक्टी डिस अलाउड में कुछ मिल रहा हमें
आईडी नेटवर्क स्टेटस स्टेटस नहीं कुछ खास
नहीं यहां पर नथिंग यर
इनफॉरमेशन वाला देख लिया हमने यह भी हमने
देख लिया आई
थिंक फर्स ग्रुप ड कॉ
अच्छा यह नॉट फाउंड आ रहा है ओके यह क्या
है भाई आई डोंट नो स्ल रोबोट मुझे क्या
मतलब है मुझे रोबोट ड एक्सटी पढ़ना है तो
ल ओपन रो डाउनलोड हो गया अच्छी बात है
बेकार चीज
है यह देख लेते हैं ओपन
करके ट बम पज नॉट एक्टिव ग्रेट चलिए
अब यहां पर शॉर्ट बाई प्रमोटेड है शॉर्ट
बाय यहां पर कर लेते हैं स्टार्ट डेट
स्टार्ट डेट शॉर्ट बाय स्टार्ट डेट करते
हैं ठीक है डिसेंडिंग ऑर्डर में
स्टार्ट देखते हैं क्या
है वर्ड
प्ले स्टार्ट डेड में असेंडिंग ऑर्डर में
करते
इसको पुरानी वाली जो चीज है ओहो सबसे पहले
बकरा उडगा था चलो ये आया फॉक्सी काट ये
क्या है भाई फक्सी काट लेट्स ओपन इट लेट्स
ओपन f का गाइस f का प आ गए एम fox.com चलो
fox.com प चलते हैं क्या दिक्कत है एम
fox.com
गुड लेट्स ओपन fx.com
स्
रोट t लेट सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग
हियर रिडक्ट हो जा रहा है ंग है यहां पर
तो कुछ ऐसा मिलेगा नहीं आपको तो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है भाई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है यह डेमो वाला
है सो रिमूव इट चलो य अच्छी थी वैसे फक्सी
काट वास
गुड सिक्योर ड्रॉप देख लेते हैं किना
सिक्योरिटी यू कैन ट्राई इट आउट नॉट एन
इशू
इसलिए होमवर्क नहीं किया था टेल मी हाउ टू
हैक स्कूल वेबसाइट वो अच्छा सिखा देता हूं
अभी मैं होमवर्क करने का हैक करने का
सिखाता हूं थोड़ी देर में सिखाता हूं ठीक
है थोड़ी देर में होमवर्क हैक करोगे सिखा
दूंगा टेंशन मत लो थोड़ थोड़ी देर और यहां
पर रुके
रहो टेंशन ले रहे हो
यार क्या टारगेट है य टारगेट ही छुपा दिया
है हद
है अरे कोई टेंशन नहीं है
भाई उतना फुट प्रिंटिंग में तो क्या ही
टेंशन लेे टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक है
टेंशन किसी चीज की नहीं
लेनी इलेक्ट्रोनियम है ये 20 मिनट जी मिनट
वन शॉपिंग कार्ट है
भाई चलो देख लेते
हैं एक्सप्रेस वीपीएन है स्टिल सॉफ्ट है
कैश प है डिज स्म है तो चलिए इस पर चल
जाते हैं 20 मिड सी आइए भाई सीच वाले स्लश
रोबोट्स अच्छा कई बार रोबोट टीटी को ना
बड़े-बड़े जो रिसर्चस है वो इग्नोर भी मार
देते हैं ठीक
है वो क्या सोचते हैं अरे रो में तो क्या
ही होगा लोगों ने खोजा ही होगा एंड दैट
व्हाई दे इग्नोर इट तो ये जो चीज है ना ये
आप ध्यान में रखिएगा कई बार ऐसा होता है
तो इसलिए छोटी-छोटी चीजों को देखना चाहिए
ठीक है तो यहां डिस अलाउ में सीएमडी है
जेसन है स्टेटिक सर्च आर्काइव आर्काइव है
क्या भाई कि ये देखो अब कुछ आर्काइव मिल
जाए तो क्या दिक्कत है स्लैश आर्काइव पे
अगर कोई आर्काइव रियल में मिल ही जाए तो
हमें क्या टेंशन
है क्या है भाई
ये हैं
आर्काइव में कुछ मिला हमें बट कुछ काम का
नहीं
है जेसन क्या जेसन है
भाई नहीं
है एनीथिंग एल्स स्ल
सीएमडी अ ये कमांड प्रम तो खोल के देंगे
नहीं भाई है
ना चलिए अच्छी बात
है और भी वेबसाइट्स है क्या इनके
माय
शॉप सेम रोबोट्स को फॉलो कर रहे होंगे सेम
रोबोट फॉलो हो रही होगी य पर भी
रो गव इट ट्राई नहीं नहीं हो रही है ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं वन शॉपिंग
कार्ट वी कैन ट्राई इट आउट स्
रोबोट एकस य गेट समथिंग एक्चुअली डिसला
अरे बापरे गजब का डिसला का इनका
डायरेक्टरी है हां अलाउ क्या किया कुछ भी
नहीं वेब पोजीशन वेब ऑटोपायलट क्या बात
है और कुछ है क्या इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग यार नहीं दिख रहा मुझे यार
कुछ पाथ हो को फिर फज करके ना ट्राई मार
सकते हैं
अपन इंटरेस्टिंग पास ले लो यार फज करो मैं
बोला था ना तुम लोग निकल जाओगे फिर बाद
में अच्छा बैकअप बैकअप जो है ना बैकअप
बैकअप मुझे मिला है हां तो ये एक्सेस
डिनाइड है इस पे हम डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स कर सकते हैं ओबवियसली दिस इज अ वेरी
गुड अ पाथ टू फज ऑन तो लेट्स गिव इट
अ अ फज
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ओके इट्स गोइंग ऑन गोइंग
ऑन गोइंग ऑन गोइंग ऑन कुछ मिलेगा तो
बताएगा देखते हैं कुछ मिलता है कि नहीं
हमें 12000 वड लिस्ट है हमारे
पास कुछ भी इंटरेस्टिंग मिल गया
ना मजा ही आ जाएगा तुमको कुछ तो मिला भाई
कुछ मिला क्या नहीं नहीं कुछ नहीं मिला
मुझे लगा वी गट
समथिंग कुछ नहीं मिला ी गट नथिंग
यार ठीक है फज इस पर बैकअप प तो कुछ हमें
नहीं मिला बट ऐसा नहीं है कि बैकअप में
नहीं मिला तो बाकी चीजों पर नहीं मिल सकती
है बाकी किसी भी चीज पर मिल सकती है ठीक
हैड
ओके
अनाउंसमेंट
ओके ट्यूटोरियल टूल बार प्रोमो साइन
अप स्टेटन ठीक है
ट्रायल अच्छा यह ट्रायल वाला भी देते हैं
क्या कुछ जिसको बंद करके रखा
है ट्रायल पर क्या है
भैया अच्छा ये क्या है कस्टमर कैचर
हैं ट्राल में कुछ भी कुछ और ही है ओपन
हुआ है अरे इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिल सकती है
भाई स्ट्रीट ऑन यह देख लेते हैं स्ट्रीट
ऑन करके
[संगीत]
ओपन हां चेक आ आउट क्या है यह भाई स्ट्रेट
ऑन क्या है जॉइन अस
सक्सेस कमाल है भाई सीक्रेट
कॉ मास्टर इंटरनेट मार्केटिंग secret.com
साइन अप टुडे
गेट वेबसाइट ठीक है कुछ चीज मिली मुझे
यहां पर तो वी कैन गिव इट ट्राई ऑन दिस
पाथ टू सो लेट्स गिव इट ट्रा
र आन
य ऑन
फज एंड ट्स इट लेट्स
चेक चेक चेक चेक चेक एंड
मेट देखा मैंने बोला था ना सब लास्ट में
निकल जाते हैं लास्ट में नहीं रहता कोई
लास्ट में सब भग लेते हैं नहीं रुक पाएंगे
ना अभी तो तुम लोग दो घंटे नहीं रुक पाते
पा घंटे तो क्या रुकोगे अरे कुछ तो मिला
मुझे कुछ नहीं मिला यार मुझे लगा कुछ आया
क्या मजा ही आ जाए कुछ आ तो ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं इसमें कुछ नहीं मिला हमें कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
यार ल ट्राई टू शॉपिंग कार्ड से हम हट
जाते हैं एक्सप्रेस वीपीएन क्यों
भाई क्यों भाई एक्सप्रेस
वीपीएन
कुछ छुपा के रखा है क्या हमसे robot.txt
के अंदर में हां कुछ तो हाइड कर रखा है
कुछ भाई तुमने डिस अलाउ एसेट फ्ट्स हट ये
क्या है भाई डिस अलाउ ब्लॉग लेटेस्ट ब्लॉक
टैग ब्लॉक टैग तुम लोगों ने कुछ नहीं हाइड
करके रखा हुआ है तुम लोग अच्छे बच्चे नहीं
हो
ओके
एक्सप्रेस अच्छा ये अनियन है क्या
अच्छा स्टिल सॉफ्ट क्या है भाई
ये एटलस लेसियन ओके ओके
ओके ओके कैश प कैश प की कोई भी वेबसाइट
वैलिड है क्या बात है कैश कैश डट प चलते
हैं जो कि हमें पैसे ही पैसे देने वाले
हैं रोबोट एक्टी और इसमें मुझे मिलेगी एक
मस्त कोई इंटरेस्टिंग चीज अरे बाप रे कुछ
तो मिला क्या है भाई रिसिप्ट वेरीफाई
वेरीफाई ईमेल वेरीफाई एरर बिटक
बिटकॉइन नो इंडेक्स नो इंडेक्स में है
यहां पर डेवलपर्स ईमेल इंडिविजुअल टैक्स
इंफॉर्मेशन लॉग इन लॉग इन लॉग इन लॉग इन
लॉग इन लॉगइन बिटकॉइन इंडिविजुअल टैक्स
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या है भाई ये तुम लोग
इंडिविजुअल टैक्स इंफॉर्मेशन रखते हो क्या
भाई गलत बात है यार ये तो क्या है ये
लॉगिन टू एंटर योर टैक्स इंफॉर्मेशन
अच्छा
अच्छा स्लश डी पे क्या है भाई तुम्हारे
मुझे देखना पड़ेगा कुछ है नहीं डी पे कोई
बात
नहीं स्ल एप पे क्या है यार मुझे यह भी
देखना है प पे क्या है प प प ही है
क्या
ईमेल अच्छा स्ल ईमेल पर क्या छिपाया भाई
मुझे को देखना पड़ेगा ईमेल भी नहीं कुछ
अच्छा कुछ है नहीं यहां पे वेरीफाई एरर
वगैरह पेमेंट्स कुछ खास इंटरेस्टिंग मुझे
कुछ मिल नहीं रहा
यार कोई बात नहीं नथिंग इज यर जस्ट लीव इट
नाउ डीजी स्टोम डीजी स्टॉर्म भैया कहां है
आप इनके मेन वेबसाइट प चलते हैं ये तो
सैंड बॉक्स वाली इमेंट इने दे रखी है मेरे
को तो मेन वेबसाइट प ट्राई मारने
का dj.com एंड गिव इट अ ट्राई ऑफ स् रोबोट
टी एक्ससी देखते हैं कुछ इनके अंदर है कि
नहीं यह एक रिसोर्स
है जो इन्होने हाइड करके रखा हुआ है जो कि
403 फॉर बिडेन है और इस पर मैं चलाऊंगा
डायरेक्ट बूट फोर्स 43 है तो मुझे चाहिए
डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स स्प लेट्स गिव इट
डायरेक्ट पोस्ट थिंग टन टना टन स्ल एफ यड
जड देखते हैं हां क्या हुआ भाई रोक दिया
तुम लोगों ने रोक दिया इन्होंने चलो कोई
बात नहीं रोक दो क्या ही कर सकते
हैं कुछ इस तरीके से आपको अप्रोच करने हैं
गाइस यू हैव टू फाइंड प्रोग्राम्स यू हैव
टू हंट फॉर देम यू हैव टू सी कुछ है क्या
उनके अंदर robot.txt में फिर उन पर ट्राई
मारो फिर उन ट्राई मारो फिर ट्राई मारो
कुछ इस तरीके से चीजें करनी है ठीक है
तो अ जस्ट गो एंड ट्राई इट आउट ऑफ
robot.txt एंड आई होप कि आपको सारी चीजें
जो है ना वो अच्छे से समझ में आई होंगी यह
बताइए कि robot.txt को एक्सप्लोइट कैसे
करना है क्या-क्या स्टेप्स लेने हैं
क्या-क्या चीजें आप कर सकते हैं एंड किस
तरीके से आपको
google2 फोर्सिंग करनी है यह सारी चीजें
करनी है एवरीवन गॉट समझ में आया और ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग का बॉब शूट के थ्रू मैंने ऑलरेडी
आप लोगों को बताया हुआ है अगर आपको नहीं
याद होगा तो पहले की वीडियोस में मैंने
क्लस्टर बॉम अटैक का यूज करके यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड फील को ब्रूट फोर्स करना ऑलरेडी
बताया हुआ है ठीक है तो अगर इसमें नहीं
बताया मैंने वो चीज तो उसका टेंशन मत
लीजिए ऑलरेडी ये चीज कवर्ड हो चुकी है ठीक
है आप लोगों को याद है ना मैंने ब्रूट
फोर्स का एक बार दिखाया हुआ था एक क्लास
में आप लोगों को याद है एवरीवन
रिमेंबर डिड यू रिमेंबर हमने ब्रूट फोर्स
का एक बार किया हुआ था एक क्लास में
क्लस्टर यूज करके हमने पेलोड वन प यूजर
नेम दिया था पेलोड टू पर पासवर्ड दिया था
जिसने फॉलो किया होगा कंपलीटली ना उसको
ध्यान
होगा दिखाओ कौन सा एडमिन पैनल मिला हैक
स्किल्स किस पर मिला एडमिन पैनल भाई लिंक
दो उस परे भी ट्राई मार सकते हैं कक स्केल
गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड
एडमिन पैनल का कुछ है लिंक हो तो दे दो
किसी को अगर एडमिन पैनल मिला है कोई सा भी
यू कैन प्रोवाइड द लिंक
यर ठीक है चलिए सो गाइस लिंक तो शायद नहीं
आएगी मेरे ख्याल से यहां प आपकी मेरे
ख्याल से लिंक ऑफ होता है तो चलिए आज के
धमाकेदार सेशन के को यहां समाप्त करते हैं
नेक्स्ट सेशन में भी इसी तरह का प्यार
दिखाइएगा मजा ही आ जाएगा फिर तो और भी
धमाके चीजें होंगी जाइए और अब जो क्या अब
क्या काम है आपका मैं आपको बता देता हूं
robot.txt को
google.doc का भी यूज़ कर लीजिएगा
google2 पे क्या है अगर एक्सेस नहीं होता
है एक्सेस डिनाइड आता है उसके बाद भी
एक्सेस हो रहा हो या नहीं हो रहा हो फिर
भी आप एफएफ यूएफ का यूज करके डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स कीजिए देखिए कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
डायरेक्टरीज तो नहीं आ रही है वहां कोई
अगर लॉगइन पेज है तो वहां पे एसकल
इंजेक्शन का पेलो ट्राई कर सकते हैं वहां
एक्सेसेस के लिए ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं
देन अगर कोई पेज आती है नॉर्मल सी पेज है
तो उस पेज को आप क्या कर सकते हैं सिंपल
उस पेज को आप बब शूट में सिंपल क्रॉल
कीजिए बब शूट में ओपन कीजिए बब शूट पे
उसमें बब शूट से आप स्पाइडर कीजिए वहां
देखिए उस पेज प कुछ आपको इंटरेस्टिंग कोई
एंड पॉइंट कुछ ऐसा मिल जाता है तो उस एंड
पॉइंट पे ट्राई की कुछ कुछ अलग-अलग वन
बिलिटी फाइंड करने का तो ये सारी चीजें
कीजिए एंड एंड यू मस्ट गेट समथिंग कुछ ना
कुछ आपको मिलेगा ठीक है एंड इस बात की मैं
आपको गारंटी देता हूं ओके सो काफी लोग
काफी कुछ कर रहे हैं ऑलरेडी अगर मैं आपको
दिखाऊं गाइस
तो लेट मी शो यू
वंस लेट मी ओपन द पेज एंड यहां पे मैं अगर
एनालिटिक्स में आपको दिखाऊं देयर आर सॉरी
एक्टिविटी में तो देयर आर मल्टीपल पीपल हु
आर डूइंग ग्रेट थिंग्स हियर
ठीक है तो काफी कुछ कर रहे हैं यहां पे
लोग टैग करते हैं हमें तो आपको भी टैग
करना चाहिए जब भी आप कोई बग बाउंट में कुछ
भी कर रहे हैं रिसोर्सेस वगैरह तो जैसे
यहां पे हमारे निखिल भाई का निखिल पटेल
शायद यहां होगा भी वो ठीक है तो निखिल भाई
का यहां पे एक हॉल ऑफ फेम भी आया था तो
इन्होंने पोस्ट भी किया था टैग भी किया था
तो ऐसी चीजें देख के बहुत अच्छा लगता है
सो ही गट हॉल ऑफ फेम सो आप भी ऐसा कुछ अगर
आपके अंदर है कुछ ऐसी चीज है यू आर डूइंग
समथिंग देन
प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू टैग अस ताकि
हमें पता चले और हम उस चीज को फ्लोट फ्लोट
कर पाए ठीक है सो बस गाइ आज के लिए बस अ
सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही थैंक यू सो मच अ
फॉर अटेंडिंग दिस सेशन एंड आई विल मीट यू
इन द नेक्स्ट क्लास गाइज टिल देन बायबाय
टेक केयर गुड नाइट एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में बहुत जल्दी ठीक है तो आ जाइएगा
नेक्स्ट क्लास में सभी लोग उड़ते उड़ते या